mindfulness is about this it is about
finally waking up one day and saying I'm
the boss of being here I have a mind I
can do better with it than letting it
scare me all the time then letting it
remind me of everything that ever
bothered me that's not fun is it right
if I say you're going to give a talk in
your class all right A lot of people the
mind gets a little trouble before that
doesn't it oh my God what if I forget my
lines does anybody's mind ever do that
to them doesn't that help you perform
better no it doesn't so I could just sit
here for the whole hour and a half and
remind you of how ridiculous it is what
goes on inside your head right it is
worse than an arm that won't stop doing
this and some people sit there and say
they want to sit there and say but it's
beneficial to go over this stuff yes if
something happens to you and you make a
mistake sit down look at it pay
attention learn from it then for God's
sakes not for the next 20 years why they
do that if I hadn't done that this would
have happened do you understand that you
can't tell me there's a benefit there is
no benefit it's just that you haven't
learned how to work with this thing
called mine hey it's Evan Carmichael and
I'm make these videos because I need
them because I don't always wake up and
feel motivated to go take on the day and
the thing that saves me that helps me
every day is being around people who are
thinking bigger who are changing the
world and it gives me a little more
inspiration to go after my mission and
so I hope this video helps you go up to
yours today too so today let's get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only Michael a singer
Joy
if you're not here take care of yourself
psychologically inwardly what I call
your inner being you're gonna make
yourself sick and then you'll have to go
out and compensate for that by doing
things that make you feel better I was
everybody says I need this in a
relationship I need this I need money I
need things I need education or what I'm
not okay
all the things they're saying I'm not
okay with myself I'm not okay inside I'm
not whole I'm not complete all right and
so basically I need to get things
outside to compensate for what's wrong
inside because spirituality says and
what I've learned over 50 years of doing
this this thing is why are you not okay
inside you've learned how to have your
body be okay reasonably not always but
reasonably right why is it not
reasonably okay inside to where you feel
love all the time sure you can share it
with somebody but wouldn't it be nicer
not to need them to be a certain way for
you to feel loved but for you to feel
love and you share it you share it I'm
far more consistent it's it's cleaner
all right for both of them and you right
and you realize that's true of
everything so there's a state inside of
ourselves
where we have risen above we talk about
Primal biological well there's Primal or
basic psychological okay I need things
I'm not okay I feel insecure I need to
prove myself I need to be treated a
certain way I just over and over and
over you've built this self-concept of
how thing how I need to how things need
to be for me to be okay how's that
that's right right hasn't everyone done
that how do things we all we all do I
mean we all do at times or all the time
okay well since there's only one world
out there and every one of us has a
different idea how it should be I wonder
whether so many wars and divorces and
everything else that's why right it's
inevitable okay and so you get to the
point where you realize I can do better
than this just like you can do better
than smoking or hurting your body but by
not taking care of it I can take care of
the inside better than compensating and
expecting the world to make me be okay
when I'm not okay basically there are
three
categories or groups of objects of
Consciousness that your Consciousness is
aware of one is the outside world if you
close your eyes you don't see the
outside world if you open your eyes ah
there it is okay it comes in I discussed
in the book goes deep tries to be
somewhat scientific so that we fit into
an intellectual model because everything
is logical and and intellectual and
reasonable so the fact of the matter is
most people don't think about this you
don't really see through your eyes your
eyes are sensors we call them senses but
they're sensors if they computer sensors
that are picking up light
turning it into signals that are being
sent up your nervous system you know
Optical nervous Optical nerves and then
it is rendering it inside your mind just
like you look at a flat scene scrap
excuse me a flash screen TV and you look
at it in there that's hard for us to
relate to because we're used our mind is
so intelligent that it creates 3D and
depth perception and everything even
though you're actually back in here
watching what's coming in and I like to
have fun with people I say I'll prove it
to you that it's really just light
that's bouncing off of objects and
coming into your eyes right turn off the
lights
and you won't see anything because then
there's no light bouncing off of things
that's not how we think we think you
draw the lights therefore I can't see no
it's because I turned off the light
there's no light bouncing off the
objects and coming reflecting back into
your eyes it's kind of neat isn't it all
right so it's it's fun to talk about
this stuff so one thing of the three new
circus is there's an outside world with
all of its objects and there's a lot of
objects out there the second is that's
not all you receive inside not all
you're aware of inside you're also aware
of thoughts which I'm sure we'll be
talking about deeper uh so just surface
level it you're aware of thoughts that
go on in there are you not right you
notice your thoughts are talking to you
you notice you can make your thoughts
think different things so you the
Consciousness the exact same
Consciousness that is aware of the
outside world is aware of your thoughts
they're not separate not categorizing it
this is the Consciousness here's my
thoughts that's the Consciousness this
is the world you can do them both at the
same time they're looking at something
and thinking about it and you're same
Consciousness is seeing both and then
the third is your emotions which are
quite different than thoughts and I'm
sure we'll talk more about that but
basically emotions are feelings their
vibrations that come up they're not
thoughts or thought forms you can
actually see a boat in there you can see
you know see words but you can hear
words they're talking to you that voice
inside your head emotions are like that
they're just basically shifts in energy
patterns vibrations that you pick up but
they're very strong and they catch your
Consciousness so those are the three
things in the threething circus the
outside world that you're aware of the
thoughts that are inside your head your
mind and the emotions that emanate from
your heart and the Consciousness gets
distracted by those things that's so
it's really funny that the word
distraction becomes a spiritual word
people think of it that way but deep
spirituality deals with distractions
that's what's all about if you weren't
distracted by your emotions distracted
by your thoughts or distracted with the
outside world you're sitting in some
body the Consciousness would be able to
come back into its source there are
things I've learned during my life how
did you learn them not by reading by
having experiences right I experienced
that if somebody really loves me I feel
better I've experienced that somebody
goes out with my best friend I feel
worse I feel that if I have the money to
feel secure and take care of things and
do what I want I feel better if I don't
I feel worse so we're programmed by the
experiences we have it in a sense it's
not our fault because we all have
different experiences to say it's not
our fault it doesn't mean we can't do
something about it right it just means
you have to understand have compassion
that we all had different experiences we
all went through different things and
they left different Impressions on top
of us I don't care if you're in prison I
don't care for the CEO of somebody
company I don't give you rich I don't
care if you're poor it's same thing's
happening all right you're having
experiences and they're either making
you feel better and making you feel
worse and you get programmed like data
that now I know what kind of things
makes me better now I know what kind of
thing that makes me feel worse so if I'm
not feeling well inside I'm going to try
to get those things to happen I'm going
to try to compensate for my lack of
well-being by external situations and
that is what causes all the trouble not
just troubled people in prison that's
why we have wars that's why everybody
gets divorce that's why drugs every
single thing is going on because I'm not
okay and like you said if I am okay
inside which we will talk about can you
be and how do you be but if I am okay
inside I don't need the outside I don't
need it to be doing things for me or
against me I don't take it that way I'm
whole and complete Within Myself I feel
love I feel Joy I feel inspiration no
matter what's happening all right
because I live inside of me so that's
that's the foundation for a good
discussion is is that true and everyone
knows it's true I've never had anyone
anyone I've done this I'm a teacher 50
years all right I've never had anybody
say that's not true no matter who they
are the situation they're in that if
they're not feeling well they try to
figure out what can I do to feel well
and if they are feeling well in order to
figure out how do I do to keep it
so you're always struggling like Buddha
said
Buddha's first Noble Truth is all of
life is suffering doesn't mean you break
your arm all the time right it means
that's what's going on inside of you I'm
not okay and I have to struggle to be
okay or I'm okay and I have to struggle
to keep it that way if you felt full and
whole and complete inside yourself right
you're welcome to share that but you
don't need things to be okay all right
so you start looking to say well why am
I not okay why am I not okay and that is
what the essence of what we teach which
is if you will look you are wise enough
everyone is to see you're not okay
because you stored every single thing
that ever bothered you for your entire
life inside of you if somebody said
something you didn't want to hear if
mommy did something daddy did something
you didn't get the toy you wanted your
first girlfriend dumped you whatever it
is if they came in there and didn't feel
good I know what you did with it you
pushed it away
right you can't change the experience
because it already happened but you can
work with or manipulate what it feels
like when it comes inside so the
experience happened outside came in
through your senses and now it's inside
of you what are you going to do with it
instead of saying which a wise person
would say this was not a nice experience
I don't want to keep it right I can't
change it it actually happened but I
don't want to keep it in here we don't
know how to do that we've never taught
how to do that so what we do is say no
no I don't like this that should not
have happened right and we push away the
inner experience even though the outer
experience already happened we can't do
anything about that so we push the inner
experience away and someday you will
everyone will hope will understand when
you do that you just destroyed your
Interstate what do you mean you just
stored something that bothers you it
will come back in your dreams it will
come back if somebody said something and
will come back as you thought something
it's still in there isn't it 20 years 30
years later Troy says it's in there you
know from childhood all through your
entire life also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all of the
Lessons Learned in this video as well as
pull out our three favorite learnings
and quotes that will inspire you to
actually do something the worksheet will
also give you space to write down what
your key takeaways are and your specific
plan of action to make sure you're
getting results if you want the
worksheet designed specifically for this
video absolutely for free there's a link
in the description below go click on it
and start building the momentum in your
life and your business I'll see you
there I don't want to see what I'm
looking at that's what judging does you
have to be excited I remember when I
first got to the point that instead of
thinking that stuff inside of me that
was causing all this trouble was what I
don't want is terrible it's keep me from
God I try to meditate above it or do
anything I can to get rid of it and then
I realized no this is what's keeping me
from God therefore if I see something
it's exciting
you have to change your entire attitude
about yourself the worse it is inside
the better
the more trouble it causes oh my God I
got myself a big fish you have to feel
that I am willing to deal with this
stuff I am willing to look at this stuff
not get in it well that's the whole
thing psychology goes the wrong way they
get you started right but we're going to
see the difference between spiritual and
psychology as we go through this so
first you have to be awake if you are
not awake what does that mean I'm not
awake we talk about it spiritually right
they're awake not enlightened just awake
what does it mean it means that normally
the stuff that's going on inside is so
overwhelming it is so strong not only do
you not want to look at it and you can't
deal with it but you are lost in it
you're in the Rapids drowning
well you can't very well be outside
looking at the Rocks you're trying to
survive you're trying to keep your head
above the water aren't you right you're
trying to take a breath trying to
everyone not go down three times that's
where a normal human being is is they
are in the fear of drowning so they're
not looking what's causing it they're
just trying to stay keep their head
above the water can you relate to that
all right the worst our times are the
more we're like that you have to be able
to get out of the water which is again
witness Consciousness your Consciousness
has extricated itself from being in it
it didn't get rid of it yet but it can
watch it it can see it and how do you do
that meditation meditation is great
mantra's great see all of a sudden
there's techniques but the techniques
are not about going to God the
techniques are about first getting out
of the water well why would meditation
work because the noise that's going on
inside of you is creating disturbance
when you sit down and meditate what
you're sitting there saying I don't care
how you meditate your business when you
sit down to meditate you're saying for
let's say 15 minutes in the morning 50
minutes in the evening that's what
nowadays they teach you guys fine all
right you sit down and for this 15
minutes it's not about going to God
that's why people can't meditate because
they just set these standards and then
they burn themselves out it's not about
seeing blue pearls it's not about seeing
white lights it's not about going to God
it's about I have set aside 15 minutes
to practice being aware
of being aware that's what it is
don't come to me and say I can't
meditate I said well there's no such
thing I understand why he said well
every time I sit down my mind just goes
crazy it won't stop it keeps talking I'm
going to touch your feet I'm going to
promote them to you bow down I'll touch
your feet you'll have to come back three
times where you figure out what I'm
doing all right you just told me that
for 15 minutes you were the witness of
your mind
my mind won't shut up it keeps talking
about this somebody's watching so during
that 15 minutes you actually watch that
your mind wouldn't shut up that's a very
high state
do you see why people screw up
meditation because they Define
meditation as the mind's shutting up no
that's not that's just a state that you
can have there but if your mind doesn't
shut up and you're aware that your mind
doesn't shut up if your heart is
bothering you and you're aware that your
heart's bothering you I was trying to
meditate but then this thing came back
up from before that bothered me I don't
know why but happened years ago my heart
started hurting and I just sat there and
watched it like good
how do you work on yourself
in this
what we call the pathless path in the
path in which life itself is your path
it is your Guru it is your teacher all
the circumstances of life
are attempting to free you to liberate
you how do you do that work
first you have to stay conscious
some people still lose their Center
what does that mean you're there you're
saying I'm going to work on myself and
now I'm going to go into this room or be
with these people or have this
experience and usually it bothers me but
I'm not going to let it bother me I'm
going to stay very aware and conscious
of what's going on and then I'm going to
come out of the room and I'll be so
excited that I was able to stay the same
before I walked in the room while I was
in the room and when I came out and you
say that to yourself you should do that
you literally should do that you should
remind yourself that that is your goal
when you walk in the room not to impress
people not to do this not to do that
your goal is now I'm centered and calm
here I am I would like to walk in the
room sit down do whatever's going on
be a proper participant and when I leave
be right back where I was before I
walked in without any loss of continuity
of purpose or consciousness that's a
true meditation deep Center
Karma Yoga is about everything else
that's why Karma Yoga is the deepest
yoga it's not about your relationship
with your body with your heart with your
mind or even with your higher bodies
it's about your relationship with the
rest of the world with the rest of
what's unfolding in front of you how do
I interact with the reality of life that
keeps manifesting before me that is the
topic of Karma Yoga and it's often
considered the deepest yoga because it
is so expansive in one's life in fact
one of the deepest spiritual scriptures
in yoga the bhagavad-gita is considered
A Treatise on Karma Yoga
so what is karma yoga what is our
relationship with the world around us
in order to understand that to begin to
truly understand that you have to
understand two things one who are you
who's in there looking out what is the
nature of your being that has a
relationship with the world around you
and the second is what is the nature of
the world outside of you
first is actually quite simple
you are the one who's in there looking
out
this is what the essence of witness
Consciousness and Krishna murder used to
talk about objective observation
you are the indwelling being who looks
out through your eyes hears through your
ears you are the one who knows you have
a body you're the one that was in there
when you were six years old and when you
looked in the mirror you saw a
six-year-old's body now you see whatever
age you are and it will continue on you
are the Consciousness the awareness of
being you see the emotions that are
coming up from your heart you see the
thoughts that are created in your mind
and ultimately you experience great love
and sometimes Bliss as you get deeper
within yourself it's all the same you
there's just one of you there that's you
well what is the nature or the reality
of the world outside of you that is one
of the most fascinating and beautiful
topics
if you turn to science they will tell
you that 13.8 billion years ago there
was this big bang
and subsequent to that there were these
thick gases of hydrogen and helium that
fused together based on gravity and
built the universe as you know it
a wise person realizes that every single
moment of their life
what is unfolding in front of them is
the result of 13.8 billion years of the
universe unfolding and evolving until it
finally landed at their doorstep and
presented the moment that's in front of
them
to them
so the world outside of you is not of
your own making
the world outside of you belongs to
science belongs to God it belongs to
Evolution it belongs to cause and effect
it is indeed the moment in front of you
took 13.8 billion years to get there
you can't call it your own you didn't
make it you weren't even here
the other way to know that the world
outside of you has absolutely nothing to
do with you it belongs to itself is to
realize that the moment in front of you
is no different than the moment to your
left or the moment to your right or the
moment behind you or the moment anywhere
else in the universe the universe is
expressing itself
everywhere you're just seeing one
particular moment one particular point
you can't say that because it's the part
that you see there's something special
about it it's just the part that you see
so a wise person comes to the point of
realizing that they are inside looking
out what is outside is the result of
creation it is not theirs it doesn't
belong to them it is just passing by and
they just happen to be seeing that
moment so karma yoga raises the Deep
question what then is my relationship to
the world that's unfolding in front of
me if it doesn't belong to me and it
doesn't again let's spend one more
moment with that if I picked you up out
of the moment you're in
and dropped you onto a street in Paris
then that would be the moment you see
obviously that moment was there before
you got there and if I take you away the
moment will be there after you leave it
has absolutely nothing to do with you
eventually a wise person realizes that
it's true of every moment if I walk in a
restaurant
that restaurant exists before I got
there it was going on the people were
there conversations were going on music
was going on whatever food was going on
I then step in I'm just seeing a moment
that already exists when I step out the
moment will keep going on it doesn't
belong to me it belongs to itself
belongs to science belongs to God
it's such a beautiful thing to see that
the world outside of you exists
independent of you but you are
experiencing one particular moment of it
this whole thing about abundance and
attracting to yourself what it is that
you want and how to use mantras and
spirituality to make sure you have what
you want true spirituality is about not
wanting true spirituality is about being
filled with joy from inside and then
sharing that outside it's not about
attracting to yourself what you want is
there a law of attraction people ask me
is there a law of attraction yes and you
better be scared of it because if it's
true that you attract what your mind is
thinking you better take a look at what
your mind is thinking it's not only when
you're sitting there trying to attract
something to yourself with affirmation
what about your mind all day when it's
complaining and it's yelling at people
and it doesn't like stuff but if you're
attracting that way so you eventually
catch on that it is not about getting
what you want
it is about learning to find out that
what you really want is to stay open and
not have conditions on that openness and
then it comes down to how do you do that
are people capable of doing that or is
that just reserve for you know some
special beings Buddha and Christ that
have walked the face of the Earth
everybody is capable of that how do I
know that
if I tell you to pick up five thousand
pounds you may not be able to do that in
fact you won't you won't be able to do
that so I've told you to do something
that you've never done and you're not
doing it so you may not be able to do it
but if you're actually already doing
something
you're already doing it and I tell you
not to do it you're always capable of
that because you're the one who's doing
it
so inside you are the one who's closing
your heart you close it you are the one
who's closing your mind you do that
they're your thoughts it's your feelings
they're nobody else's so you are in
there doing these things so if I tell
you the way to stay open is to not close
I don't teach how to stay open that's
more like finding out how to get what
you want I'm interested in you learning
to not close but a difference if I say
to you I want you to open your heart
right now you wouldn't even know how to
start
but if I say to you somebody says
something you don't like don't close you
know where to start right because it's
happening inside of you and you see the
tendency to do it all I'm asking you to
do is don't do that I'm telling you that
will take you the whole way don't worry
about opening worry about not closing
there are going to be events that unfold
in your life that naturally open you a
beautiful sunset a bird singing
sometimes you get what your mind wants
all right you open great nothing wrong
with that don't close
how come it only lasts a minute how can
I see a beautiful sunset you feel like
oh my God I looked into the face of God
then you go right back into your mind
with all your problems why
why don't you learn to not close once
you get some openness start to work with
yourself to not close and this is how to
get what you really want to teach the
Deep spiritual teachings are really
teaching you how to get what you want
because what you want is to feel love
and joy and happiness all the time
and so if you can get that from within
you then can share it one of the things
the Mind does is develop methodologies
or ways of thinking that let it interact
with life and not get hurt and be more
comfortable and it's the ego when we
develop a self-concept and we change it
through our lives but in general there's
a self-concept sitting under there
saying I was the one that did this and I
was the one that went to the school and
I'm the one that went there and the one
that my father left or stayed or
whatever the hell it is excuse me and
basically uh all of this unfolds and you
end up developing patterns of thinking
based upon the experiences you've had
all right and what I'm saying at least
certainly in my experience is that's not
what makes you wake up that's what keeps
you from waking up
all right the fact that you're
identifying with these past experiences
and saying that's who I am well it's not
who you are you are watching your ego
you see it get upset you see it fix
things you see it have Concepts and
Views and Etc et cetera and even you're
obviously very intelligent you can use
your intellect to support the ego to
support that and and so on right and I'm
sure yes you're a very special person
you're an intelligent person and
therefore that becomes part of your
self-concept okay and then you say a
religious person part of your
self-concept all of these things are
ways you think of yourself and there's
nothing at all wrong with that it's
wonderful you've been successful you're
happy you're doing well all right I'm
not happy I'm not doing well I just said
that
and also like weeping openly at this
moment okay but listen to me right that
identification with your personal self
which is just your mind's thoughts are
what keep you from waking up when life
strikes us and we feel that internal
reaction to the external world it's
still what's going on inside how do we
release that how do we let that go so my
experience is first of all there are
things you can do but the same things
everybody else teaches which is don't
hit somebody don't learn to shut your
mouth up you know don't let that Express
through your mouth because you're going
to pay for that right so the first thing
is a certain amount of self-control
which we all need in order to be
successful right but that's not the
answer yeah right the answer is every
single moment it's not the big stuff
that you work with that's too late it
already bothered you it's you gotta yes
you have to deal with it yeah but what I
want and what I've learned is there is
every moment of your life little things
that create little irritations the
drivers driving 15 miles an hour below
the speed limit in front of you and
you're in a rush it rains when you have
to get out and deliver something it's
hot it et cetera et cetera right
somebody doesn't say hello hey Sally how
are you doing oh my God you will watch
your mind cause serious problems all
right so to me that is where the growth
comes from in those moments are you
willing to say come on what's the cost
benefit analysis of bothering myself
about the driver in front of me it's not
bothering them I guarantee you they're
not hearing a word you're saying right
so as a business person we're supposed
to take cost benefit analysis the
maximum benefit for the least cost those
are 100 cause zero benefit right or
wrong it's all pain so you don't do it
so you learn and there are lots of
techniques you just learn to work with
yourself you can neutralize it by saying
something nice you can get a mantra
going inside so you pay attention to
something else instead of that or my
ultimate teaching and this year's also
in a sense is you're relaxed and you
relax you just sit there and say I can
relax and breathe it's okay that this is
happening and then what you're doing is
allowing the energy to release the whole
idea is you don't engage with it yes you
sit behind it and you allow it to
release and not only do you go through
that moment okay now right but you've
actually let some of that stored up
stuff that's causing the problem like
what is road rage it's somebody who
because somebody beeped at them or is
driving slow has so much stuff inside of
them that it needs an excuse to come out
yeah that's it okay so we all I hope I
we I hope we don't all right but we all
have stuff inside that we've stored over
our lives so by backing off and letting
go in these simple little situations
they matter it matters that you're
complaining about the heat yeah you're
saying that right It's Not Innocent
you're you're permitting suddenly you
get very angry about some stupid thing
you're giving a channel for your stuff
to come up and you're wired yourself to
complain exactly what's wrong and so
instead you relax it's called r r you
get r r relax and release yes right and
what will happen is not only do you make
it past that moment without causing a
lot of trouble and taking out all kinds
of stuff but you've let some of that
stuff go and you get into the habit of
realizing hey I don't want that stuff
inside of me instead of looking at the
decision you're trying to make ask
yourself what are you trying to get from
this decision what's your motive what
you're going to find out is every single
time it is either I'm trying to make a
decision that will make me feel better
make me happier in the future let me
achieve a better State inside myself or
a more content more excited more
enthused you know feel higher et cetera
or I'm trying to make a decision that
will save me from having to experience
something that I don't want to
experience which way can I choose this
so it's a path of least resistance so
you find that the motive behind your
decision as opposed to getting all
involved in the decision if you step
back and say what am I trying to achieve
and you're going to see that it's either
a desire or a fear you're trying to
achieve a desire by moving to New York
or moving to California which won't work
for me right you're trying to make your
mind be psychic to figure out which one
women make you happier versus I'm trying
to avoid a situation that I don't want
and then you take a look at that and you
realize what I'm really trying to decide
is how to be happy inside how to be in a
better State inside myself well why
don't I say that honestly it's not
really about this decision it's about
how can I find a more beautiful state
inside myself and that's where it leads
to yoga that's where it leaves
everything leads to spirituality because
it says the state you're looking for is
inside yourself what are the words that
got to do with where you live or what
your job is or who you marry it's got to
do with how you're doing inside yourself
why don't you work on that a little bit
instead of trying to put the burden on
your mind of thinking that some decision
you're going to make down the road is
going to decide the quality of your life
because the truth of the matter is the
state of your being is going to
determine the quality of your life if
you're whole if you're complete if
you're enthused if you're filled with
love it doesn't matter which place you
live in you could be wonderful and if
you're disturbed inside it's not
California New York that's going to make
the difference it does for a short
period of time because it's new and
therefore you're more open to it so you
step back behind the decision and you
look to see where you're coming from and
at some point if you come deep enough
looking at that you'll realize I have
put a burden on my mind of saying this
is going to determine the quality of my
life and it's not true you're going to
determine the quality of your life to at
least come back to that Center that deep
Center inside that undercuts all this
then you're going to find out that you
don't put the pressure on yourself with
that decision and often it will unfold
naturally doesn't mean you don't make a
decision not indecision but you'll find
that if you make get rid of the noise
inside of you you'll be able to see more
clearly what is actually happening and
what is maybe a better way to serve a
better way to balance the energies as
opposed to how can I make myself happy
with this decision or how can I avoid my
fears with this decision train your mind
not on the site but when you're
meditating when you're driving but
something train your mind to say
something over and over again all right
it can be a mantra it can be though when
people are into all that stuff I tell
them just say I can handle this
just train your mind to say I can handle
this I can handle this I can handle this
then when something takes place that
tries to pull your Consciousness your
awareness into that negativity you'll
find this is still going on because it's
a habit the mind's full of habits isn't
it you made a good habit so now you have
a choice put your Consciousness on the
noise or put your Consciousness on the
repetitive you know the the Mantra the
higher mind yeah right and that works
too so now that you've moved your
Consciousness instead of having to
change the mind right the mind is free
to release the whole idea is releasing
because when you let it release it's
releasing the stuff that made it be like
that yeah and all of a sudden over time
right you'll start to be happier for no
reason of course there's a reason you're
not carrying the garbage inside of it
yes and you've got a new set of habits
yeah
supporting them right but ultimately I
always get in it's relaxation yes
ultimately you can use all these
techniques but when you really are
getting there you just relax keep your
hands off it's Judo yeah right something
attacked you let it go yeah right it's a
whole blade of grass versus the oak tree
yes a hurricane can't rip off a great
glass we can break broken break an oak
tree that's right you just and that's
what surrendered me surrender does not
mean not doing your best at what you're
doing and not being competitive and
giving up stuff it doesn't mean that it
means are you willing to let go of your
resistance yes
one to what's going on outside and
you're resistance to letting go of the
thing that's ruining your life which is
the stuff you stored inside yeah so
instead of asking why am I not okay well
I'm not okay you're asking what do I
need to be okay that's the major
difference of whether you're growing
inwardly or you're attached to
struggling externally is you think I can
only be okay if I get the things that I
got before
or similar you extrapolate right things
that made me had a relationship and
eighth grade and it was so beautiful and
she was redheaded okay my wife no it's
not true all right
he was redheaded and she left you know
her parents move right and it was never
a bad experience in that relationship it
was just the most perfect relationship
you've ever had right you understand now
if I'm grown up and I I go on a date and
shoot a red hat she redheaded I have a
pretense propensity toward being open
you just ask the question why do we
think we need these things all right
because we're not okay inside and we've
had experiences either you read a book
it'll tell you you need that to be okay
you watch a movie meet somebody you can
have a thought
if I had a Tesla
okay it used to be a Ferrari that's a
Tesla all right I I we had everyone
would be proud of me and I feel like I'm
helping the ecology and so all of a
sudden I'm not okay I'm going to go to
Tesla and if I get a Tesla oh my God for
a while how am I doing wonderful so
that's how you develop your preferences
is through programming you get
programmed by your past experiences what
do you really want
we talk about wisdom people talk about
attracting to themselves The Laws of
Attraction and all those sorts of things
but the question really is from a
spiritual point of view what do you
really want and religions about what
you're supposed to want and we know how
that works
spirituality is not about that
spirituality is about looking deeply
Within and seeking truth Clarity that's
what it's about so this discussion is
has nothing to do with my feeling what
you should want are you even feeling
guilty or
weird about what you do want the
question is what do you really want
and the way to do that and I'm going to
be very bad in doing this is to say
here's a piece of paper not really but
figuratively and I want you to write
down what you want just take a little
time don't do it take a little time and
write down what you want and if you're
like most human beings probably first on
the list is a good relationship
something makes me feel important needed
wanted loved secure all that kind of
stuff and so whether you're in a
relationship I'd like it to get better
or someone so should behaves different
ways should understand me better
Etc or if you're not in a relationship
how to find my quotes soul mate somebody
who just fits perfectly with me and just
fulfills the meaning of my life and uh
if we're really honest we write down a
nice house and a Ferrari or at least
some sort of a car and perhaps children
and or perhaps a little time without the
children and we make our list nobody's
judging just be honest you put that down
the purpose of this discussion is no
matter what you put on that list unless
you're very highly evolved
my experience is it's not really what
you want it's not that it's wrong it's
just not really what you want and the
way I prove that is as follows let's say
you put down I want a relationship I
want to meet somebody I want to have
that special relationship
and then I would ask you what if you
walked outside after this conversation
and all of a sudden there was this blush
in front of you and it started burning
like it did to Moses and talking to you
and its opening sentence was I am the
Lord your God
and I would like to discuss some things
with you
and said enough things that it knew
about you to where you were pretty
freaked out that you're actually talking
to an omniscient omniscient omnipotent
being or at least bush
and
the question that gets asked of you is
what would you like what do you want I
can grant whatever you want and having
gone through this exercise with me you
feel God thank God Mickey I'm prepared
this is neat I thought about it and you
say I want a relationship I want to meet
somebody I want to have that that thing
I've looked for my whole life or I want
a house or I want the perfect job I want
a job that makes me you know that that
fulfills what I'm looking for
and what this push what God tells you at
that point is I can give you that I have
the power to give you that but there's a
caveat which you probably want to hear
before I give it to you which is
I can give you that perfect person
they will be loyal to you they will stay
with you your entire life
but the caveat is
that you will be completely unfulfilled
you will feel sad every time you come
into their presence
you will not feel any love you will not
feel any joy happiness meaning but
they'll be there and they will dote all
over you and they will just be the most
perfect partner
that they could possibly be
or give you the job that you thought
would be the most amazing thing but it's
Hollow for you you go there and you
thought it would turn you on but it
doesn't
and you just Lowe's going to work and
you're just not excited about it
so therein lies there what do you really
want
because what you're going to find is if
you're given the opportunity to have a
relationship with that person I just
described or have the job I just
described but it didn't do SWOT for you
and it left you hollow inside you would
say I don't want it in fact if it's
going to make me miserable inside I
really don't want to keep it away from
me
and so to move quickly because we don't
have a little time here then I say you
lied to me when you said it was what you
really wanted
because it isn't true you wanted a
relationship it isn't true you want your
children it isn't true you wanted money
it isn't true you wanted to travel
around the world it isn't true that you
want it et cetera Etc what's true is you
want it to feel good inside
you wanted to feel love you want to feel
Joy you want to feel inspiration and
excitement meaning those are inner
things there are outer things
you listed the things you listed
because you thought they would give you
what you really want
and so wisdom yoga spirituality
is about going deeper Buddhists talk
about working at the root so the truth
of the matter is the only thing you need
to write you needed to write on a piece
of paper when I asked you what do you
really want
is a sense of total well-being
I want to feel love I want to feel Joy I
want to feel inspiration I want to feel
meaning and depth
what you want to do is say what's behind
the anxiety so when when people talk I
don't help people make decisions but we
talk about decision making is the first
thing that matters is what's your motive
not what should you do
if how can you figure out what to do if
you don't even know your motive right
and my you became the spiritual teacher
with every word you said about this
which is start from the point of view do
I want to get a house or not
well okay yes I like to have a house all
right can I afford a house don't worry
about what house what's your motive it's
very simple you know it's just I'm just
on to express myself and have a house
and and that's that and then stop there
don't say it has to be a certain way
when it's all said and done if you're
afraid of making the wrong decision who
defined it is wrong you well then don't
that's what I was saying right if you
don't Define it as wrong I was a builder
okay you know before my personal
experience before the program coming I
did built with love my company I built
this house for this beautiful lady all
right who happened to be the manager of
the local bank and her name was Penny
dollar
I swear to God her name was Penny dollar
right this is a long time ago back in
the 80s and basically she once came to
me and sat there and said I'm so scared
I said look I I'm gonna build a
beautiful house for you we've got it
everything's fine so I stay up at nights
I can't sleep what are you worried about
isn't it turning out nice I'm afraid
listen to this I'm afraid that I will
build a house and then I'll go to plug
in a lamp and the cord won't reach the
outlet
wow wow
thank you I said wow that's why they
make extension cords
I was gonna say that's why they make
therapists but yes
when I was you know 22 23 years old
I realized that that voice was running
my life
and that's what you're saying if it
wasn't comfortable I left
if it you know whatever it was it was
determining what I said it was
determined how I acted it was
determining everything about my life and
yet I didn't know a thing about that
voice why was it saying what it was
saying why why is it like one person and
not another because when you like
somebody your voice says I like her
so where did that come from right and if
all of a sudden it said no I don't think
so I don't think then you don't it's
like telling you and your emotions go
along with it and it's this whole
psychological system that's going on
inside so I made the decision not and
I'm not saying people should right but
it's nice to share that I wasn't going
to live my life without understanding
what was going on because it didn't make
sense okay and it already caused a lot
of trouble in my life just like it does
everybody else's all right it's like oh
your relations is so hard and everything
else and changing jobs it just decides I
don't like my boss I don't like the boss
anymore it's telling you that why didn't
it just say I like the boss
like no one actually pays attention to
how much control it has over your life
or why it's saying what it's saying so
what I did was to say I'm going to take
a little sabbatical hiatus about a year
or so I meant to put aside and devote my
life to watching that voice and figure
out why it says what it says what is my
relationship to it and I in essence
dropped out I don't like teaching that
now because people shouldn't drop out I
mean that they shouldn't but they don't
need to and I'm not teaching them to
right but I did I was it was a I think
you know I was in a doctoral program for
economics the university and last year
ready to get my doctorate and I stepped
aside and went into Solitude relative
Solitude and I watched very very
carefully and what I saw made me more
uncomfortable than what you were talking
about all right like watching it when it
was in this Glory because you know you
pull yourself aside it's going to say a
lot of stuff made me realize I don't
listen to that thing that thing's crazy
it just changed his mind all the time it
says this it says that like the reason
people drink and do drugs is because
that thing's driving them crazy do you
understand that are you trying to get
away from that inner mess that's going
on inside so basically over the course
of many years I started an experiment
which was what would happen if I didn't
listen to that
what does that mean it tells you what to
do and so on well what if I listen to
Life instead and that's very subtle what
if the events unfolding in front of me
were more important than whether I like
them or not
and I was willing to listen if I'm
meeting this person perhaps it has some
meaning the fact that I'm not
comfortable with them maybe has no
meaning right and I started practicing
letting go of myself instead of letting
go of what it told me to and and
sometimes it told me to do something
sometimes I wouldn't do it what I got
was as follows
just because it told me to do it is not
going to be the reason I do it just
because it told me not to do it or that
it doesn't like it it's not going to be
the reason I don't do it that doesn't
mean that I'm doing or not doing I will
let life the unfolding of Life the
circumstances that unfold in front of me
talk to me instead of that thing talking
to me so that that's the basics of what
I call surrender you're not surrendering
to life you're not surrendering to
people you're not saying yes to
everything you're just basically saying
my head doesn't know what it's talking
about it's just a bunch of noise and I'm
better off not listening to that
personal noise doesn't mean
intellectually if I'm solving a math
problem or I'm trying to decide you know
create air conditioning or building I
built for a while reading plans and so
on the mind's wonderful for that I'm
talking about the personal mind I like
this I don't like that I believe in this
I don't believe in that I want this to
happen oh my God I hope it doesn't rain
tomorrow because I'll die if it rains
that kind of junk just the personal
noise that instead of honoring and
respecting life is judging it and trying
to tell me how to make life be my way
instead of my respecting that life took
13.8 billion years to get here that's
that's a big shtick I have right that
every moment in front of me took every
single thing to happen exactly like it
did for 13.8 billion years for that
thing to be in front of me do you
understand that because if you're if
you're a great great grandmother didn't
meet your great great great grandfather
you're not here everyone
has total will over everything going on
inside over your thoughts over your
emotions and over all physiological
things within yourself that is the
nature of the indwelling Soul it is
omnipotent in relationship to itself do
you understand that
I'm not telling you to develop these
Powers they're called cities you know
these developed cities right there's no
reason to do that but I am telling you
that if you are living within yourself
and your mind is driving you crazy and
your emotions are causing you trouble
and your body
is not healthy because the food you eat
or because of this and the other thing
right you are not subject to that it is
absurd to allow that to take place sit
there and say I'm smoking and I know I
shouldn't be smoking I'm getting sick
I'm starting to get pre-cancer type
stuff but I can't stop that's absurd I'm
sorry okay I'm sorry to tell you that's
upstairs that's like saying nothing
wrong with you my arm is here every once
while it picks itself up and there's
nothing I can do about it that's not
true all right it's just simply not true
so what do you mean you can't stop
smoking I don't understand attention
right here okay I feel the urge to smoke
of course you do you're a smoker you
have a habit it's called a habit so you
have both a physiological and a
psychological habit that when you get
uncomfortable your mind starts bothering
you to get a cigarette doesn't it or a
drink I don't care what it is it's
bothering you it keeps talking about it
and it keeps saying it's okay you can
get it just one doesn't hurt you and it
does that yes or no right that's what it
means to have patterns neurological
Pathways that you carve in your neurons
right you have Pathways that are going
to start generating thoughts like this
and you have physiological urges because
they stick all that nicotine in there
and it's addictive physiologically all
right and so there's this discomfort and
therefore the discomfort physiologically
and psychologically
urges you to do something about it and
therefore you go and you do these things
do you have to of course not of course
you don't have to that's ridiculous if
you went there and tried to grab the
cigarette and all of a sudden somebody
said to you not only does that one have
the surgeon generals poisonous skull and
crossbone on it right but that was laced
with with arsenic
you put it down
straight you're gonna put that thing
down you say I want another one all
right you had the ability to put that
down there is no way you are telling me
and I won't believe you if you say it
because I know it's not true that you do
not have the ability to not take that
cigarette out that says arsenic laced
put it in your mouth and light it and
say I knew I shouldn't but I just
couldn't help myself you can help
yourself you can help yourself if you
intend to if your intention is I don't
want to smoke that you are not going to
smoke that if your intention is I wish I
didn't want to smoke because I know it's
not good for me but I really want to
smoke it you will smoke it and if
something happens that's challenging
then play chess be challenged chess
Champions put themselves in these
amazingly challenging situations don't
they mountain climbers oh my God that's
pretty challenging and life-defying
there are people that go out of their
way to purposely put themselves in very
challenging situations why
why did he do that because it brings out
the best in you it makes you dig deep
and bring out the best that you are and
makes you better than you were before
doesn't it that's why we have
competitions that's why you'd climb
mountains that's why you challenge
yourself to your limits why can't you
let the everyday events that are
unfolding in your life be your mountain
climbing
be your chess match they are just there
if they're challenging good good I'm
glad they're challenging that's exciting
that's better than being bored isn't it
it's better than just floating through
empty dark space
it is not true that when you are born
that necessarily you are more centered
in the seat of self and then some
terrible things happen and you get that
the Masters you're gonna used to teach
this says the moment the Consciousness
the self
drops into the body
the experience is so intense it's
overwhelming right it's like you're just
all of a sudden thrown into the water
with fish swimming all around you've
never been there before right it's so
distracting it's so powerful the
experience is so powerful that it pulls
your Consciousness into the experience
so that happens immediately all right
that you have become separate
from who you are because you're busy
paying attention to the object of
Consciousness instead of your seat of
consciousness
so the more distracting something is the
more powerful the experiences the more
distracting it is distracting is the
most spiritual word you'll ever use it
means it pulls you away from yourself it
means Consciousness I was looking at
that book then you started talking it
distracted me my Consciousness went to
you pull all right so when something
distracts you it draws your
Consciousness toward it so when you drop
into the body when you take birth right
your Consciousness is pulled into this
experiential
unbelievable experience of the senses
coming in of noises and sounds and
things and blah blah blah right and so
it immediately becomes distracted into
the body and into the world okay and
then what happens is it's not
comfortable there's a sense of loss of
self okay I don't know who I am all
right this is where as a psychologist
somebody says this stuff it becomes very
interesting psychology then the self is
not that the self-concept develops we do
it we pull the self-concept around
ourselves to protect ourselves the self
does that the Consciousness doesn't know
itself it loses itself it's been drawn
away from itself so there's this sense
of loss a sense of discomfort a sense of
disorientation it's very much like if
somebody has Amnesia and when they wake
up from Amnesia they're not comfortable
there's no one ever been comfortable
when they wake up and they don't know
who they are or who their family is or
where they live or where they don't know
a single thing they Panic right that is
what happens when you lose your seat of
Center itself so now because you are
uncomfortable you immediately
try to Define yourself try to cling or
hold on to things that will help you
define the reality that you're dealing
with right to orient exactly and that's
where the self-concept comes from and as
a mother you know that starts pretty
early right that they start developing
you're my mommy that's the first one
that's my daddy this is my crib the
psychologist will tell you the worst
thing you can do to a child is put them
in a different place every single night
with different toys and different people
you understand that because they can't
find the solidity of defining themselves
and so we start to develop this
self-concept in our mind that's why we
call it a concept it's not the self it's
a concept of self a concept is something
that's not real it's a mental image it's
a mental thought okay so we start to
develop in our minds this is Mommy this
is Daddy this is where I live this is my
crib this is my toy this is except
that's what the Mind comes from and
that's why they're so strong about the
mind and the terrible twos right is uh
it says not that you took my toy well
you took me
right I've defined myself in
relationship to this object don't touch
it don't take it away and it's Panic
right you see the crying and the
tremendous clinging to objects that it
is the self the Lost self the Fallen
Soul all right that has lost itself that
is trying to redefine itself and these
objects outside but that doesn't stop
with the terrible twos
we then develop not just objects but a
concept of ourselves as experiences
happen to us we Define ourselves by the
experiences we have it's hilarious right
you are not the experience you're the
one who had the experience but if I play
Dorothy in fifth you know third grade
Wizard of Oz right and I'm the big hero
and I did a great job that becomes part
of my definition of who I am if I'm 30
years later and we're talking about the
school play there's a reunion and
somebody else says I play Dorothy you
freak out well I play Dorothy in that
play you said that it's like 20 years
later you will fight for your right to
hold on to your definition of yourself
because you literally Define yourself as
the one who played Dorothy as the one
who married Paul as the one who has his
two children as as the one who went to
school over here you're defining
yourself as the experiences you went
through because those are the images
that are the data that went into your
mind and that's why everyone of us
Define ourselves separately differently
and our definitions of self keep
changing right if you say well I'm I'm
Paul's wife whatever you get divorced
right well now I'm Ben's wife like you
didn't die because you're not with Paul
you understand that but you hold on
inside of you I'm the one who had that
terrible experience with Paul so that's
how you develop this self-concept
anger
a little trouble with anger anger is
very strong right yes
all these things can be very strong the
question is your intention
I guarantee you there is nobody nobody
that is not capable of working with
their anger nobody
because you are the strongest force
inside well how come anger overcomes me
or overcomes somebody it doesn't do it
all at once it is not like you're
standing there in the middle of the
field and all of a sudden you don't
think anything nothing happens in this
roaring Beast overcomes your being all
right I mean they can be if there's
mental illness I'm not talking about
that okay I'm not saying there can't be
something physiologically wrong okay
and that that's the type by the way the
type of mental illness I just separated
out is is that there's a physiological
problem with the brain so basically now
here's how I see anger he's talking to
me he starts
touching sensitive subjects inside of me
purposely or not purposely it doesn't
matter to me it sounds purposeful I'll
tell you right now the moment that thing
starts okay and I start feeling
uncomfortable right or wrong and I start
feeling this heat building up from down
here through chakra stuff all right and
go on and I can actually feel myself
start to get heated I might even say
stop it I'm telling you I am not going
to be responsible if you keep going for
what's going to happen oh wow that's
beautiful in other words I'm still here
I'm conscious
I have my Will and I'm seeing this Force
begin to rise up inside of me it builds
doesn't it anger builds right very good
if your intention
is to not lose your temper ever
well what if the person's wrong
that's a very different intention right
what if they're trying to make me lose
my temper nah right if your intention is
to not lose your temper I would highly
advise starting very early in the game I
just talked about
all right that the moment they start
talking about a subject that you know is
difficult to you that's where you start
that your intention if you're smart that
intention and the will driven intention
is so strong that the moment that starts
you take control you step forward it has
to be that you're only intention your
only intention
is to stay centered to stay clear and to
be with your hands on the wheel
and that's how you're going to drive you
live inside you don't live outside you
live inside there's a mind in there with
you there's a heart in there with you
there's energy flows in there with you
if you leave them alone it's going to be
a mess
people don't even understand what a
message is because they don't know it
doesn't have to be that way you just get
used to living in a mess a moody you
have problems you're sensitive you don't
like things you don't get what you want
you get what you don't want you're
afraid you're desirous it's just a
commotion it's just uncomfortable inside
most people are always uncomfortable
inside very rarely are they comfortable
so what this drives you to do if you're
not paying attention and I'm telling you
people are not
it's a mess inside it's uncomfortable
inside it's disturbing inside nobody
wants to live like that
so instead of straightening it up inside
what will happen and will happen to
everybody all seven billion of you
is you will realize that certain things
can happen outside that make it worse
inside people can say things that
disturb you people who you love can
leave you you can get old and not be as
good looking as you used to being it
wrinkles in your face and so on all
kinds of things can go on and we'll go
on that cause disturbance inside
sometimes things will happen outside
that make you feel good inside but it's
not as much there are way more things
that cause disturbance that cause
discomfort that cause fears then there
are things that actually make you feel
well I'm not talking about maybe if I
get this I'll feel well the actual
moment of I feel whole I Feel Complete I
wouldn't change a single thing
everything's beautiful you must admit
you get count it on your fingers on one
hand versus the things that bother you
there Aren't Enough stars in the sky
you're always going to disturb by
something that is because it's Disturbed
inside if it is Disturbed inside then
events that unfold outside and come into
you are going to stir up the
disturbances all of us have different
disturbances therefore different things
disturb us turn us on or off so a normal
life which you don't want the normal
life of a human being on this planet is
as follows I am not okay inside I'm not
comfortable I'm always uncomfortable
it's not comfortable
I have found that certain things can
happen outside that maybe feel more
comfortable and I can find that there
are other things happen outside it made
me feel really worse so my task in life
is to try to control the environment
outside of me so that more often it
makes me feel good inside when it comes
in and less often it unfolds in a way
that disturbs and makes me worse if you
dare to be open and look at it you'll
realize that's most people's entire life
trying to figure out what they need or
want outside and what they don't want
and don't need outside and then try to
figure out how to make it be that way
and we end up going to war with reality
we end up going outside fighting with
people places things situations
everything unfolding because it's not
the way we want and then you try to make
it be the way you want and by the time
you're done it's pretty difficult to
make everybody be the way you want very
difficulty every situation unfold the
way you want it's very difficult to have
things not happen that disturb you since
it's so easy for us to get Disturbed so
it doesn't work and we end up getting
frustrated we end up getting tense and
we end up getting anxious this is the
normal state of how people live
that's a worldly life it's it's just an
external life of fighting with the
outside to try to make it so you can
live with yourself inside
there's an alternative life
it's so simple it's ridiculous
and very very few people actually walk
it
which is
I live in here
I should straighten it up
I shouldn't try to find somebody that'll
straighten up for me
I shouldn't try to find a job that will
turn me on so much that I will be
distracted by the disturbances inside of
me
I should fix what's wrong inside of me
this is my house I live in here if I'm
sensitive I'm scared I'm insecure if I
have issues going on in here that I
don't like to talk about that cause me
trouble they need to clean up I need to
straighten this up in here I don't want
to go for the rest of my life keeping
garbage inside of me and then trying to
make a life outside that either
distracts me from it
or fits what's wrong inside of me
so the great spiritual path which is
also the great way of life
is to turn this back
is to say life has the right to be the
way it is
it's very Grand of you I think right
life has the right the moment in front
of me has the right to be the way it is
there are forces doesn't mean I like it
doesn't mean it's I can give lots of
reasons why it would be better another
way than change anything I think it'd be
neat if we could fly so we didn't have
to have planes and we'd have to go
through TSA and get it all takes so long
right come on guys grow up you start by
honoring and respecting reality so you
come into the moment and you do the work
you need to do to stop making up an
alternate reality and trying to impose
it on top of reality
people get really scared with that well
how will I succeed I want to know how
you manage succeeding fighting with
everything I was like I'm telling you 90
of all of your shop to your Qi your
energy is wasted suppressing the stuff
from the past using your mind to make up
how you want it to be make all those
decisions that are so important and then
fighting with everybody and everything
and you're using so much energy you have
no idea imagine if you have taken that
golf shot and during ask your golf pro
well what I'm going to do is every
movement when I move my arms back I'm
going to think am I doing it right maybe
I should go another degree and then I'll
watch and I'll see you know see what's
right how's that shot gonna be
no one will tell you to hit a shot like
that it's supposed to be a fluid free
action period there's not supposed to be
any mind involved it is supposed to be a
complete merger of your whole being and
all of your energy into the Oneness of
hitting that ball go ask anybody all
right that's that's it that's martial
arts that's sports that's everything is
the same way with life
if you stop this mishigas this craziness
that we are doing with our minds
come into the present moment and ask
that moment what is the highest we could
do together
that's what you've asked the golf ball
that's sitting on the edge of the roof
what is the highest we can do together
how can I join you in the rough
participate in this moment and bring the
joy that can exist in this moment and do
the best that I can because the best you
can do is the best that you can do in
the moment it's not something you made
up hypothetically if you live that way
each moment will better in the next
moment you will have brought your best
game to every single moment you're doing
that goes for everything goes for
business it goes from relationships
if you're in a relationship and somebody
comes to you and says I I need to talk
to you those dreaded words I need when
you come back from work tonight that's
really nice we need to have a talk I I
I've been wanting meaning to talk to you
for a while but I've been scared but I I
I'm ready my therapist said I should
talk to you
okay all right so you're gonna have one
hell of a day aren't you you're gonna
your mind's gonna make up what they're
gonna talk to you about like this that
what you're gonna say back this is gonna
be terrible and then you're gonna sit
down and by the time you did all that
the person's gonna sit down and start to
talk and sit there saying you know I'm
really sorry you know because I I I I
care for you it starts like that but
there are just some things that right
away out of your mouth because you've
decided what they're talking about right
it's not true I didn't do that I know
you think I always knew youth I thought
that you thought that I thought that you
did that but it's not true I didn't do
it George did it he just lied to you wow
I jumped the gun a little bit here in
others what you're going to do you want
to protect yourself from something you
are not comfortable with and you're
going to try to use this conversation so
that you walk away feeling a little bit
better because you didn't feel
comfortable with it all day that's very
different then you're going to use this
conversation with this person you care
about has said I need some help with
something rather than bringing yourself
into the moment trying to see can I be
of some assistance you don't care about
what that person's going through you
care about what you're going through
because that person is threatening you
and therefore every word you say and
everything you hear and everything they
do will be about you it won't be about
them that's how it gets when the
emotions get evolved isn't it it'll be
about protecting yourself well if you
protect yourself you're the worst
partner that ever lived if you come into
that moment let go of the part of you
that is your personal come into the
moment this is your friend this is your
partner and listen to what the person
has to say literally listen
maybe you'll hear something maybe
something can be improved maybe it has
nothing to do with what you're thinking
about anyways maybe they want to tell
you I just wanted to tell you that I've
always wanted to go back to Ireland and
I know you work hard I bought the
tickets
please don't be mad at me it's for our
anniversary
[Music]
forget what I said about George
you can't have a nice life
if you're in size is that messed up and
then you try to control the life around
you so it doesn't hit your stuff so the
alternative is to say
I don't want that stuff inside of me
let's stuff any of it
I don't want any of it inside of me I
want to be open I want to be receptive I
want to be able to handle the reality
there's unfolding in front of me and
finish it off I told you I maintain a
rule I'm very strict about it not always
successful but to maintain a rule if
it's not happening outside it's not
happening inside
I give them the room if something's
happening outside and it's disturbing
okay you know that's tough it's hard but
when it's no longer happening outside
there ain't no way I'm letting that go
on inside otherwise it'll never go away
if somebody's yelling at you it's not
comfortable it's not comfortable right
then they stop yelling don't worry they
won't stay there yelling nobody ever has
and then they walk away I don't want
this to German still inside of me it'll
never go away I've got scars inside of
me because somebody yelled at me no if
it's not going on outside it ain't going
on inside I'm going to let the energy
pass through I'm going to give it the
room to finish so I don't have to carry
it with me that is the essence of
spirituality that is the essence of yoga
that is the essence of every single
thing that has anything to do with
spiritual growth you cannot have that
stuff inside of you the highest
technique you can do is to let go of
your stuff
is to basically sit there and say I
don't want this stuff inside of me I
don't care what it costs
I spend my money on lots of things you
do too nothing buys what that's worth in
fact the reason you spend your money in
a new car or a boat or a vacation is so
Disturbed inside you need a vacation
from yourself I need a vacation from
this junk that comes up inside of me and
I'm telling you that's where you spend
all your money that's why you need a
nicer house you need a nicer house
because the Jones would have a nice
house than you it makes you feel
insecure because you don't feel good
about yourself and I have people I can
get a nicer house and so everything
you're spending your money on you're
better off this is better way to spend
your money if you're going to have some
pain some discomfort and having to do
some work get paid properly and what
gets paid properly is I want less of me
I want less stuff inside the most
meaningful life is to grow what does
that mean to notice that there's stuff
going on inside of you that's not so
much fun for you or anybody else okay
can you raise above that can you change
not much I'd like to change that but
change your seat of awareness so I can
look at this part of me that you know
just silly okay I don't want I don't
give that out all right but if I
suppress it then it really becomes part
of my personality so you don't suppress
things well if I express it to let it
out then I'm dumping on somebody you
know unless you said to me don't you
talk to me like that okay I get that
well what if I step back and say I am
aware that this is upset in here I'm
aware that this inner thing where I live
my house is it's got a little tornado
going on there all right can I just
relax and step back and be aware I'm not
denying that it's happening but it's not
me I'm the one who's looking at it and
something very magical happens if you do
that enough it releases the energy to go
to a higher level like we hold you know
if you get upset but you don't want to
the best you do is push it down right we
have that tendency with hands inside
don't we right with hands inside like no
push that aside all right which is a
form of suppression you can instead
learn but it takes time but you learn to
relax in the face of all that and what
you'll find is it's all Just Energy
being disturbed and if you give it room
it will go up instead of down or out it
will go up it's called transmutation the
energy transmutes and it could start as
anger but it comes up as love finishes
when it finishes passing through instead
of hitting you and your will in there
then it shoots out it actually has the
ability to go up and if you do that
enough times
you're exactly you're becoming static
literally the energy goes up all the
time not just when things are the way
you want them to be you just relax and
the energy feeds you from inside and
there's this this River if you will of a
flow of really beautiful energy that
feeds you day and night and that is the
purpose of Our Lives is to evolve we've
already evolve you know enough tails and
we've got two arms and two legs and
fingers opposing thumbs we've evolved
pretty good outside all right good girl
you involved pretty good outside but
what about inside
yeah we can't handle anything we're
supposed to be the highest species of
the planet which is called adaptability
right but we're not very adaptable
inside are we
that's right what we like what we don't
like and we're serious about that and
you better behave the way I want you to
or I'll you know you'll pay for it as
opposed to it's just a something that
came in something that you said or
something that I thought you said and I
don't have to be like that I can relax
and then I can come with Clarity and
deal with the situation from a higher
place and that to me is the purpose of
life it's to evolve inwardly are we here
to experience the separateness as part
of being human or are we meant to
transcend it it's that we're meant to
witness it and not let it become a part
of us everything is a part of you and
I'm sure you've seen that okay
especially as you've grown through the
years right there's all kinds of stuff
in there right all kinds of stuff in
there what do we want to feed and pay
attention to and build okay as we're
growing so the first thing you do is you
you look at your person well first thing
you do is you look at your body am I
eating reasonably you've already done
all that okay you go through that Basics
if I'm eating food that's making me sick
it's silly okay I better be strong
enough to be able to rise above the
tendency to you know eat junk and to
smoke and to drink too much and Etc et
cetera right if we don't do that it
defines our life yeah you understand
that the body will then Define our life
the illnesses and discomforts of the
body okay so let's say but notice it
took Will and it took the willingness to
rise above the Tendencies yeah that the
habits that the body has formed okay so
the question you said is even with
dealing with your body which you know
most of us have done pretty good with
that at this point all right and you
wouldn't be where you are in life if you
hadn't all right so basically you write
there you use word rise above it you
rise above these Primal Tendencies to to
eat and lust and just go crazy over
you know basic biological things all
right and so you rise above that but
then you have this ego inside that
develops patterns of what it likes and
what it doesn't like and who it likes
and who it doesn't like and how you're
going to treat me how you're not going
to treat me and I don't want to get I
don't want to get old I want to look old
I I love when people do that or I don't
I don't want to look old I want to look
like I look now what was your best year
is 23 then when they ask you to go to a
conference that's the picture you send
out there even though you're 80 or here
I am right and so you develop this ego
inside a self-concept that says this is
who I am right well you can rise above
that and how you don't deny it you don't
suppress it you don't dislike it you
just say Where's that going to take me
like some people say I don't want to die
well I'm sorry every single thing that
was ever born died it's a one-to-one
correlation it's amazing all right
there's only a statistical study it was
a hundred percent of everything that was
born die so to say I don't want to die
what a ridiculous thing to do with your
life that's like a disappointment well
you'll be uptight all the time you'll
make yourself sick just like the body
things if you don't take care of them if
you notice here take care of yourself
psychologically inwardly what I call
your inner being you're gonna make
yourself sick and then you'll have to go
out and compensate for that by doing
things that make you feel better I was
everybody says I need this in a
relationship I need this any money I
need things I need a vacation or what
I'm not okay
inside I'm not whole I'm not complete
all right and so basically I need to get
things outside to compensate for what's
wrong inside what spirituality says and
what I've learned over 50 years of doing
this this thing is why are you not okay
inside you've learned how to have your
body be okay reasonably not always but
reasonably right why is it not
reasonably okay inside to where you feel
love all the time sure you can share it
with somebody but wouldn't it be nicer
not to need them to be a certain way for
you to feel loved but for you to feel
love and you share it you share it I'm
far more consistent it's it's cleaner
all right for both of them and you
and you realize that's true of
everything so there's a state inside of
ourselves where we have risen above we
talk about Primal biological well
there's Primal or basic psychological
okay I need things I'm not okay I feel
insecure I need to prove myself I need
to be treated a certain way I just over
and over and over you've built this
self-concept of how thing how I need to
how things need to be for me to be okay
how's that that's right right hasn't
everyone done that how do things we all
we all do I mean we all do at times or
all the time okay well since there's
only one world out there and every one
of us has a different idea how it should
be I wonder why there's so many wars and
divorces and everything else that's why
right it's inevitable okay and so you
get to the point where you realize I can
do better than this just like you can do
better than smoking or hurting your body
but by not taking care of it I can take
care of the inside better
than compensating and expecting the
world to make me be okay when I'm not
okay what work is to most people
is an answer to problems they have I'm
not okay so I go to work to earn money
so I can enjoy the weekends so that I
can go travel so that I can have
vacations
I don't feel tremendous meaning in my
life so I go to work to feel like I'm
contributing to feel like I'm succeeding
in something I'm not sure of myself work
gives me an opportunity to prove myself
in other words work is about me my work
is not about work work is about me what
I can get from it what it can do for me
what is my career what is my growth path
etc etc of being able to prove myself
and compete with others it all ends up
being a place that I'm going to get
something
that is not what work is work is the
exact opposite work is a place I go to
serve work is a place I go to contribute
to the unfolding of the universe
a wise person gets to a point where they
understand that every single thing in
creation has something to give it has a
contribution the Stars the earthworms
every cell within your body all of these
things contribute to make the whole you
are part of that
so you have a job to do that job we call
your Dharma your work you don't have to
look for it it's right in front of you
it's always right in front of you it's
not just the fact that you get up early
in the morning and go to a particular
place it's the fact that you take care
of the kids it's the fact that you
contribute to the community whatever it
is that you're doing that's being asked
of you that is put before you is your
work
so the whole attitude about work needs
to go through a reset
once you go through that reset and you
understand there's not something wrong
with my work there's something wrong
with me it's just like a relationship
you don't get into a relationship
because you want something from somebody
that I'm not okay and somehow magically
this other person is going to make me
okay you get into a relationship because
you're filled with love you're filled
with joy you're filled with excitement
and you'd like to share it work is
exactly the same you go to work because
you want to express yourself you go to
work for the same reason that an artist
Paints in her spare time in the woods
when nobody will ever see the painting I
have something within me that wants to
express itself and work is the
manifestation of that expression and
someday you're going to find out that it
doesn't make any difference what you're
doing
it is the expression and the act of
doing it that brings about joy that
brings about fulfillment work is not a
place that you go to get something so
you can be fulfilled work is a place
that you go that in sharing and giving
you achieve a state of fulfillment it is
an end within itself and if you work on
yourself you will find that work is your
spiritual growth wisdom yoga
spirituality
is about going deeper Buddhists talk
about working at the root so the truth
of the matter is the only thing you need
to write you needed to write on a piece
of paper when I asked you what do you
really want
is a sense of total well-being
I want to feel love I want to feel Joy I
want to feel inspiration I want to feel
meaning and depth and you made the
mistake of doing what I call indirectly
by saying I want something outside that
I think will make me feel that inside
so without belaboring the point to go
deep and to really be on a spiritual
journey you don't let yourself do that
anymore
because I'm sure there are plenty of
times that you said oh my God if only
this happened I'd be fine and you know
that didn't turn out that way even if it
did for a moment it didn't stay that way
it's not like there wasn't anything else
you ever wanted and likewise if
something was bothering you you sat
there and said if only that would go
away it'd be fine that again is not the
truth
so you come down to the point where
eventually be totally honest with
yourself may sound selfish but you'll
see in the end it's not
to where you say I want to be happy
I want to feel love I want to feel Joy I
want to feel inspired I want to be
turned on inside all the time so now if
that Burning Bush was sitting out there
and you were wise enough that when God
said to you what do you want and you
said that whoa you're a winner right how
can you lose if from the moment you wake
up in the morning you're turned on
you're inspired you're excited you can't
wait to see what's going to happen for
the rest of the day and you embrace it
totally and then at night you've given
everything you have you put your head
down you fall asleep you wake up again
I'm back ready to go that would be a
beautiful life and that's what you're
looking for you just think you need all
these things in order to get that
so now we go to the next step of what do
I really want
and the question that gets asked by a
person who's deep and wants to go
spiritually is
yes I want to feel okay in the side
that's really what I want the outside is
not what I'm about it just seems to in
my past I've had the experience that the
outside changes how I feel inside and
that's what a wise person starts to
realize that if certain people walk up
to me and they say certain things at
just the right time in just the right
way it turns me on
if the same person walks up to me at the
wrong time and says the wrong thing in
the wrong way it turns me off
so I now have taken on the task of
manipulating controlling everybody who
walks up to me so that they say it right
what I want at that time and they don't
say what I don't want and it just comes
down to I have this list of what I want
and what I don't want and most human
beings most means 99.9 have devoted
their entire life to getting what they
think they want and avoiding what they
don't what they think they don't want
and the emphasis on the word think
versus it becomes much simpler when you
realize what I want is to be okay I want
to feel love I want to feel Joy I want
to feel happiness and inspiration
so now as you look at that the next
question becomes why don't you
because your experiences I can only feel
those things if the outside comes in
through my senses in a certain way
so the depth where you start to get
spiritual and you go deeper into this is
you ask why is it like that why is it
that if I get what I want it turns me on
and if I don't get what I want it turns
me off and forget what I don't want it
definitely turns me off and if I don't
get what I don't want I feel relieved we
take that for granted Yogi takes nothing
for granted a spiritual person questions
everything why is it that the only thing
that really turns me on is when the
outside world is exactly the way that my
inner State decided it wanted to be
hope you're enjoying these sharings that
we're doing about the workplace and how
to make every moment of your work
experience a spiritual experience and
part of your son part of your spiritual
practice
I thought we'd take a real fun one
which every one of us do regularly in
the workplace which is what's so
spiritual writing an email what's so
mindful about writing an email how do I
bring Consciousness to play and use it
as my spiritual growth in writing an
email
truth of the matter is writing in the
mail is a very very important thing to
do you are communicating with other
people so it has a whole aspect of
communication and you're also putting
yourself out there
where I grew up in the size business
that I worked with we were told every
single email you write imagine on the
front page of the Wall Street Journal
so that's a whole other aspect of
mindfulness is what you write matters
it's not just some innocent little thing
and when you talk
right unless somebody's recording it's
said and it's gone an email is not that
it is a permanent record and it can be
used as such you have a lot of
interesting Dynamics in writing an email
one is that which is you best watch what
you say and the other is obviously you
have something to say you wouldn't be
writing the email so you have to
communicate it's just a wonderful case
of mindfulness so the first thing you do
when you sit down to write an email is
Center always Center I don't care if
you're just saying yes sending an email
back with a reply how many times have I
hit a reply and I thought I hit reply
and hit reply all not too many thank God
you have to be conscious every single
step of the way so you start off with am
I just responding to the person who sent
it to me as a reply or is what I'm going
to say something that should be sure to
other people that's what mindfulness is
all right it is being present and making
a conscious decision instead of letting
habit and mindlessness
cause of trouble so to me even that act
helps you spiritually
the moment in front of you
is not bothering you
you are bothering yourself
about the moment in front of you
that is always the truth
that's a very hard truth to digest I'll
tell you that right now
your mind does not agree with that
but stop for a moment
and let's talk about it
the moment in front of you
isn't bothering everybody else maybe
they're sure bothering you
so either the moment in front of you is
bothersome
or it's a moment
that's something that I try to get
across in the new book
every moment in the universe is a moment
in the universe that's all it is
I'll drop you down at some place in
Paris and there's something going on
a movie 10 feet away there's something
else going on
bring it back to Kansas and drop in
Wichita
and there's something going on
no matter where I put you
there's something going on
now I'm going to ask you a math question
how many different things are there
going on at the same time on the planet
Earth
there's no numbers big enough foreign
trillions and trillions of things are
going on at the same time
if you're willing to let go of yourself
you will realize they're all the same
they are what happens to be going on on
the planet Earth at that moment don't
worry it won't be gone in the next
moment
and they won't before it doesn't happen
again ever ever
to the moment you happen to be standing
in front of
is just a unique moment in time and
space and you just happen to be standing
there
it's not personal
how can it be personal there's 800
billion of them and that's just on Earth
what about the rest of the place
are there moments going on there are
there moments going on in every place in
the moon most go on every place
everywhere well that's a lot of moments
and you just happen to be standing in
front of one of them
it has nothing to do with you it's not
personal you didn't make it
it's just like a movie moving through
and it passes by
it can't bother you
but you can bother yourself about it
and I'm gonna tell you a secret
if you don't bother yourself about it it
will bother you
will not bother you want Iota how do I
know because there's 700 trillion
moments that are not bothering you
they exist you'll say every the moment
and they're not bothering you why
because you're not bothering yourself
about them if I pick you up and I drop
you there you'll bother yourself about
it well why did your body yourself about
it before I drop you there
the same moment same thing
you have to be willing to let go at that
level
if you want to explore the Deep States
the moment in front of you is not
bothering you
you are bothering yourself about the
moment in front of you
why don't you learn to not close once
you get some openness start to work with
yourself to not close and this is how to
get what you really want the teeth the
Deep spiritual teachings are really
teaching you how to get what you want
because what you want is to feel love
and joy and happiness all the time
and so if you can get that from within
you then can share it and again this is
not selfish what did Christ say one of
his favorite teachings right man does
not live by bread alone but by every
word that leaveth the mouth of the
father only a yogi a spiritual being
knows what that means it means you don't
live off of what's coming in from
outside bread is much bigger than just
eating it's all of these circumstances
that we need that feed us all right you
do it by tuning into the energy within
every word that leaves the mouth of the
father that's where the spiritual energy
is coming from it's coming from a spirit
so as you're in there working with
yourself you will find out that if you
don't close you have access to that
energy all the time and I mean all the
time no matter what happens to you no
matter befalls you if people are
dishonest with you if you don't get what
you want and somebody else gets a job
you want if you don't get the raise you
want these are not these are not
terrible things these are things that
make you close
and when you close you give up the
meaning of your life you give up your
joy you give up your beauty you give up
your love you fall in love with somebody
that's beautiful it's wonderful they do
something they slurp their suit they
leave the cap off the toothpaste they
whatever it is they pull the blankets
off in bed right they just do some silly
little thing and I'm telling you you're
gonna close
why would you trade love which is so
precious for a stupid little thing like
your mind not liking some little trait
that somebody has
I'm encouraging you to look at it that
way and say I'm ruining my relationship
and giving up Love by deciding to not
like what this person did or deciding to
not accept this or accept that that's
why now you're at the core of
spirituality acceptance acceptance
surrender what does it mean it means I'm
not going to let the outside world close
me I have the right to have it beautiful
inside nobody has the right to take that
away from me this is my world I live in
here and that becomes your spiritual
work you're trying to make your Neurosis
or your anxiety relax no anxiety doesn't
know how to relax anxiety is anxious
you're saying that this is nature right
it's all jumpy and stuff like that right
but you who's noticing it you has the
hands in there you can relax you can sit
there and say okay fine just relax and
lean away from the noise just go to that
place okay that's like a Zone like what
I'm saying the athletes talk about being
in the zone right there's a Zone inside
if you relax behind that noise there's a
piece back there there's a there's a
quiet that would be a big spiritual
experience but it's a heck of a lot
nicer to hang out with anxiety yeah it's
the Observer that's what it feels like
you're the Observer and you relax and if
you do that over time not immediately
but over time you will find that that
which was making you anxious the
Neurosis downstairs oh my God my boss is
going mad I told him I'd be there I'm
going to be lit you can be just as late
anyway sorry it's not going to change a
thing you look at that and you realize
I'm okay I'm okay it doesn't do any good
to show up neurotic okay so you let go
and as you let go you'll notice amazing
thing that energy that was all weird
because you didn't touch it it changed
it was able to come up all right or you
start using affirmation right you sit
there and say oh come on this is
probably a an older person like my
grandma
that's right they get to drive and I
should not be talking at them or
bothering them or even sending them bad
vibes maybe they should not be driving
any faster well well and the point is
it's the latter part of their life and
at least they get to go some places or
something it means a lot more to them
than this Neurosis means to me and you
feel like you're giving something
instead of demanding and taking you can
change yourself it's not about
suppressing it's not about denying it's
about raising you raise yourself pausing
almost feels like it generates
compassion a little bit what you'll find
out is you back there are the most
beautiful thing in the whole universe
you are filled with love you're filled
with compassion you're filled with
inspiration you're filled with Michael
shock the energy the spirit energy quote
whatever you want filled with it all the
time but you're busy looking down at
this garbage and so you learn to raise
yourself the other example that I like
to use because I'm very much into
being Broad and seeing the whole
universe instead of just your little
tiny world right is let's say it's hot
out nowadays we have global warming
we're hot okay it's very hot out you're
standing there and you have to go from
one place to another and you're actually
outside with no air conditioning isn't
that terrible and as you're walking
you're complaining oh my God it's so
freaking hot and I'm sweating I don't
want to sweat I don't like this sort of
thing and I always have to be so hot
what's wrong with these people Bubba
okay well that doesn't help anything it
doesn't make it cooler it doesn't do a
single thing it's the same thing like
the car but what if you sat there I know
I trained Mickey this I trained Michael
this way all right as I sit there and I
look and I say how did it get hot be
quiet how did it get hot what do you
mean why is it hot
well because there's a sun out there you
mean there's a star
93 billion miles away and you're it's
hot it's so hot that you feel is heat
here I'm in Gainesville Florida Miami is
about 300 miles away I asked them how
big would a fire have to be in Miami for
you to steal it in Gainesville if the
whole town caught fire you would not
even know what happened that thing's 93
million
it's 95 Million Miles Away
and you can feel the star shine okay you
can feel is that mean and all of a
sudden it's like imagine me that's right
yeah I can feel a star the stars are
neat things right and you start working
with yourself that way and it works you
raise yourself
we call a mindset it's a conditioning of
the mind that makes it so that things
turn you on and turn you off and that's
where you get your list of what you want
and what you don't want it is not true
that you want those things
what you want is something that will
open you so that you can feel the joy
that is natural when you're open and you
don't want the things that close you so
that you get blocked off from any joy
and you get this sense of depression
so you have a choice even right at that
point and we haven't even gone deep yet
you have a choice do you want to spend
your life
deciding what you want and what you
don't want and then chasing it outside
or do you want to sit there and work
inside to realize all I really want is
the joy and the love and if I stay open
I can have those I don't need outside
conditions to keep me open so I make it
I make a very important point because in
spirituality it gets mixed up
spirituality is not about renunciation
there's no renunciation pronunciation
says I've decided what it is that will
make me happy and I'm not going to do it
well that sounds rather absurd all right
spirituality says it was stupid of me to
decide what will make me happy instead
of being happy with life instead of
being grateful and turned on by all of
the amazing things that are happening in
front of me and all the past experiences
I got to have why don't I just enjoy all
that and then come into life filled with
love filled with joy and give the hold
of my being to the moments that are
unfolding in front of me that's what
spirituality says so it's not about
renunciation it's not about things are
wrong and things are right
it's about understanding that you did
this you did this with your mind you set
up conditions in which your mind would
open and then your heart opens and
conditions in which your mind will close
and your heart closes so spirituality is
very positive you'll say spirituality is
not logical and rational it is so it's
saying to you why are you doing that if
you want to have a beautiful life spin
around a planet in the middle of
nowheres why don't you just open it's
your heart it's your mind it doesn't
need conditions to open it's just you
don't know how to do it it's you've
become used to programs uh habitual that
you had a past experience as by the way
this is where it comes from how did you
decide how did your mind decide what it
is you want and what you don't want you
did not make those decisions they were
programmed into you by your past
experiences all of them so you had a
past experience where something was nice
with a certain person they looked a
certain way they had a certain name they
drove a certain kind of car whatever it
is and you really was really was high
for you it was beautiful years and years
ago now one of those things shows up you
meet somebody with that name as shallow
as that sounds don't kid yourself you
meet someone with the name of your ex
you close down even though it's not the
same person you meet someone with the
name of who you had your first date with
in high school that it was a wonderful
relationship and you open up and
likewise when you see a car they had a
nice experience in it turned you on so
you are programmed by your past
experiences such that if they were good
experiences they tend to open you when
something reminds you of them when they
were negative experience they tend to
close you and that is where you get your
list of what you want that's why all of
our lists are different everyone's
listening is totally different someone
tells you this is the same as yours
they're manipulating you because
everyone has had different experiences
and based upon those experiences it left
these Impressions on your mind and you
came up with this list of what I want so
when you make the list of what you want
what you don't want you're really making
a list of your past
that's how you came up with those things
even colors that you like anything
there are Impressions Skinner the
psychologist said man is the sum of his
learned experiences it's not true it's
true that your mind and your heart are
the your personal heart are the some of
your learned experiences but you are in
there noticing this so I make a big
distinction with me right that you are
in there and you are noticing that your
mind is a sum of learned experiences and
it is that's what psychology meets
spirituality psychology is right all of
the psyche your thoughts your patterns
your likes your dislikes your problems
and neuroses Etc are the some of your
learned experiences but you are in there
you're the Consciousness the awareness
of being who notices that what I'm
saying is true
so basically you come to the point where
you have to decide do I want to continue
letting my past leave Impressions on my
mind and my heart such that only certain
things will open and close me and then I
will spend my life chasing after
manipulating controlling conniving
whatever you want
the world around me so that sometimes it
unfolds the way I want or do you want to
sit there and understand that you're the
one who's making these decisions it's
your mind who's setting up the
conditions why don't you just not do
that
start with positive thinking that's one
level that at least you should be doing
that right you sit there and say we'll
make it through this and even if I don't
whatever it is I will be a better person
because of this if you're in into God
running everything if that's your state
God knows what he's doing there are so
many different things that you can do
with positive thinking to create a nicer
environment inside in my opinion you
have an obligation to do that both for
yourself for the health of your body for
people around you you just lift yourself
up and he just says one should raise the
selfless self not trample down the self
this is a time to be doing that work so
you can't say I can't do that you can
make your mind say things you're going
to use to say every time there's a
negative thought replace it with a
positive one it's a good time to
practice that so it's it's woeing for
itself oh my God this is terrible I'll
be fine this is okay God knows what he's
doing or you know there's just reality
it's just reality except either way and
then the next level is you sit there and
if you do Mantra and Mantra doesn't have
to be an Eastern you know Sanskrit
Mantra but just get something going
behind that you're hanging on to it a
deeper part of your mind I'll be okay
this is okay I'll use it whatever it is
right then what will happen is when the
lower self starts these situations
happen you just settle back into it so
you have a choice which mind you want to
listen to the lower mind which we know
what it's like or you've built something
beautiful inside and then ultimately the
highest state is you relax every single
time something hits your stuff you relax
you relax relax and let go relaxing
itself is Letting Go people sometimes
say well I relax how do I let go the
very fact that you chose to relax relax
your shoulders relax your tummy Etc and
and just relax inside you that is
Letting Go you're not getting all
involved in what's going on so that's
the highest state is you just keep
letting go and the worse it is the
better is keep letting go you just to
commit yourself I'm going to use this
all right then you of course put aside
some time in the morning and evening to
remind yourself that this is what I'm
doing I would love to feel that
what we talk about today and what you
end up doing with it can help you be the
best of whatever you chose to be because
we're talking about it's your choice
what you choose to be all right and you
have a lifetime to do it but there are
things that can help you be that and one
of those like I said the most simple
level is you take decent care of your
body if you don't take decent care of
your body it doesn't do well does it and
when it's not doing well you can't do
well you can't go to work you can't
concentrate and so on
I want to talk about what mindfulness
really is Right gets pigeonholed into
different things it really is about
saying can we have a discussion about
what you're doing with your mind there
that's mindfulness
be mindful of what you're doing with
your mind so what does that mean you
raise your hand you say to me well I use
my mind to study I say wonderful great I
hope you do well at it I use my mind to
do research I'm into research wonderful
that's a great thing to do with your
mind I use your mind I love to read and
learn about history and whatever it is
that you are doing with your mind that
is fine be mindful of what your mind is
doing or you're going to be in big
trouble
what is your mind doing it's really very
very easy
I guarantee you it takes you 10 seconds
you won't like what you see what you're
going to see is that when you are not
using your mind when am I not using your
mind when you're driving down the road
going somewhere when you're sitting on
the potty whatever you want to call it
right all the moments you take in your
life where you are not consciously doing
something I guarantee you there's
something going on in your mind what's
it doing oh my God I can't believe I
said that I am so embarrassed that was
ridiculous if I hadn't said that I was
doing this anybody's mind do that answer
me okay what is the benefit of that
the answer is zero do you understand
that how about this you're driving down
the road you're going on a vacation or
driving to Miami and there's a sign a
billboard on the road and it reminds you
of a relationship that you probably had
with your father or your mother 25 years
ago and your mind starts reiterating the
discussion as if it was going on now or
your ex-husband or whatever it is and
it's still going on in there isn't it
what in the world is that of what
benefit is that very few of you in
business in relationships in life would
allow a cost-benefit analysis take place
of which the cost is 100 and the benefit
is zero and you would still do it
correct that's what I'm telling you that
is the cost is a hundred percent and the
benefit is absolutely zero all it does
is cause you trouble it makes you
neurotic it makes you nervous it makes
you scared do you understand that so why
are you tolerating that that's what
mindfulness is about we Define a world
inside ourselves that supports our
self-concept and we need that because
we're hiding from ourselves behind the
self-concept right and because we Define
the world that way we need the world to
be that way right but the world has
nothing to do with what we made up the
world is what it is it's reality it's
it's beating to a whole different drum
it's beating to science it's beating
like they're not rain today it's my
birthday that's stupid John what are you
doing in the rain has nothing with your
birthday has to do with meteorology and
low pressure zones right so you've now
left yourself vulnerable to the
unfolding of reality
is going to destroy you
right so that's what you were saying and
that's absolutely true so even if I sit
down and I write my list
to begin the day
and then I follow that list in order to
basically make myself feel less insecure
the truth is I'm more vulnerable yes
because things may interrupt that list
that I don't have control over and then
I will be sort of subject to that
experience
if you're living your life to hide from
yourself
you're not going to get anywhere
it starts you ask me how do you do this
it starts when you say I don't know what
that anymore
I don't want my state of being to be
completely dependent upon somebody
else's mood upon how somebody else does
or doesn't do or
et cetera et cetera from the unfolding
of the weather or the unfully of the
world right I want to find my true being
I want to find me in here and be okay
then I'll come into the world it's not
that you don't come in the world let me
come into the world and be motivated by
love be motivated by compassion be
motivated by creativity by inspiration
instead of be motivated by fear which is
what we are motivated by right okay it's
like the most powerful of us try to stay
really powerful because the thought of I
mean some of these very powerful people
the minute they're out of office or out
of this or finances go wrong they're
jumping off buildings
right or wrong
it did happen didn't it right okay
that's because they were not powerful
they were supported by something because
they were needing and then that it was
weak and that strength came from
conditional like a conditional State the
moment that conditional State went away
well it's over I don't want to face this
these things inside are our darkness and
you call it transmuting right that we're
transmuting this energy that we've
stored and and he also say the energy
wants to go up right is that right
always always it always wants to go up
right and it's funny you call it
Darkness that's like saying that that
night is darkness that is not Darkness
the sun is shining out there exactly the
same as did the entire sign for 4.5
billion years there's no Winters or no
summer there's no this or not right it's
because something's blocking the light
it's not that the light is not there
right the cloud is blocking the light if
you you don't have to find the light
right you know to make light underneath
the cloud get rid of the cloud and
there's nothing but light
that is your natural state it's your
natural state right period period and in
The Beautiful People start to realize
that that hey I made a mess of myself
nobody else did it right they did things
that I couldn't handle but I'm the
person that couldn't handle them and I'm
the person that then stored them inside
and made myself angry and made myself
fearful and weak and or whatever all
right I did that I'm in here let go let
go of the cloud I don't want to call it
Darkness let go of the cloud let go of
the blockages that you put in there and
store it in there even if somebody did
something terrible to you they didn't do
it inside they did outside right you
understand that right yes yes you don't
have to keep it inside
I've kept lifetime lifetimes of my
parent with my parents and my sister and
my boyfriend all these things that
happened to me have just
clouded my my life yeah made a mess in
my life my inside life that makes a mess
of your interstate and then what you try
to do is manipulate the outside to make
it feel better
understand it what can I do to distract
myself from that and what can I do to
make sure that everybody behaves
everything the weather everything
behaves in the way I needed to so when
it comes in it doesn't hit my stuff
and it never behaves in a way that hits
my stuff you follow me yeah next thing
you know you're just manipulating and
struggling whereas open up to life
there's nothing wrong Life Is Life you
know is it right no is it wrong is it
just no is it fair no it's just life
right the Buddhists say very deep it's
deep stuff right then Buddhism says
flowers are red
the water is blue and the grass is green
that's the teaching go there was things
things are the way they are
you understand that you're welcome to
say I want to flowery be blue and the
grass to be whatever all right that's
just your stupid mind
fighting with God fighting with reality
right so instead you just be willing to
say okay nobody said it was fair nobody
said it was just nobody said anything
they just said reality is reality it
happened you can work with it to make it
better in the future but you can't do a
thing about the past
until they develop time machines that
ain't gonna happen so you have to accept
the past let go of the fact that you
couldn't handle it before now you're in
a better position to raise the future
otherwise all you're trying to do is
make sure the future doesn't do what
bothers you in the past and does do what
made you feel good in the past and since
we all had different experiences we're
all fighting with each other as you
become clearer
and life you realize that spiritual
growth
and personal growth
are exactly the same thing
they're just looking at two sides of the
same coin why is that
spiritual growth is supposed to be about
God
and personal growth supposed to be out
making something good of yourself
cleaning out yourself raising yourself
I would prefer that nobody knew anything
about God
that they only knew about cleansing
themselves
because
if you're not there yet
God's just gonna be a concept to you A
belief
wishes of no use nothing
if you work with yourself to raise
yourself
you will come into a state where you
will understand what they meant by the
word God you don't have to use the word
God use any word you want
it's just describing a state of being
so what does it mean to grow personally
it means to notice that you have issues
inside yourself
you think you ever should outside no you
have issues inside
there are fears insecurities desires
needs wants
self-consciousness embarrassment guilt
these are all words that describe things
going on inside ourselves
guilt is not something outside it's
something inside need is not something
outside it's something inside
yes you're guilty about something yes
you need something or you think you do
but the actual experience is inside of
you
those experiences these terrible things
I just talked about that's how you go to
God
those are your pathway you kind of
ignore those you cannot run away from
those they are literally the road map
of achieving spiritual States
you eventually as you grow spiritually
come to realize there is no stress
there's only resistance energy is coming
in a given Direction
and if you are participating in that
dance of that energy there is not stress
if you are resisting at all whatever
degree you're resisting resistance
creates stress it's the same thing with
engineering do you know that i-beams
that they build buildings with they
measure stress that's because there is a
force that is opposing them and that
creates stress nothing in isolation has
stress so the question isn't what's
going on outside again as usual with me
is the question what's going on inside
if you are feeling uptight if you are
feeling stressed out if you're feeling
burned out
I appreciate that I respect that start
looking inside at a minute by minute
level as you go through your day where
am I resisting where am I resisting what
is it that a phone call happens fine I
told you it's a phone call you're
sitting on the planet Earth and you get
a phone call that's exciting here you
get the entertainment of a phone call
you have this opportunity but that's not
how you look at it if you look deeper
inside you'll see I'm afraid of failing
I'm afraid something will go wrong I'm
afraid I'll get in trouble I'm afraid
I'll get yelled at or I'm afraid I won't
get what I want I want to get something
from this how do I get that fear and
desire create stress why because fear is
saying I don't want something to be the
way it might be or the way it is and
desire is saying I do want something to
be the way it's not right you don't ever
desire what you already got
and you know fear was not happening it's
something is happening and you have
resistance to it that's what creates
fear something isn't happening and you
want it to that's what creates desire
both of those are coming out of yourself
that's your personal self fears and
desires there is no stress without fears
and desires there's just the beauty of
the experience the awesomeness I mean do
you feel stressed when you look at a
beautiful sunset do you feel stressed
when you hold your beloved in your arms
oh I held you too long
you don't do that all right because you
are open you're receptive you're
completely open to the experience why
are you not open to the phone call why
you're not open to the meeting why are
you not open to going work why are not
opening to put in a couple extra hours
if you have to there's a whole stack of
papers left over there you would never
want to see what I took home every
weekend right and I never felt burned
out I never felt stressed it was passion
to me I wanted to do it I wanted to have
it run the best that it could I wanted
to help everybody so you look inside and
say don't let people tell you well of
course you're burned out you're working
40 hours or whatever you've been doing
the same job for such and such no it is
not true you're burned out and you're
stressed because you're resisting and
the only reason you resist are fear and
desire your blockages are blocking this
beautiful flow of Shakti of energy it
doesn't want to be blocked it will push
them out of the way it happens every day
of your life
stuff gets pushed up you're driving in
the car you're doing okay and all of a
sudden this thing comes up you remember
what your mother did what your father
did what's your first boyfriend I hurt
you you see a sign that reminds what do
you do boom push it right back down
how do I deal with this I'm telling you
the Shakti the spirit the QI down there
is going to push this stuff out of the
way it does not want it to be there it
doesn't want blockages to be in the way
of the flow just like the river doesn't
but you will not let it happen will you
there's no way if all of a sudden you're
sitting there and somebody said
something and you feel the insecurity
you felt when your father yelled at you
you do something to avoid that tell the
person to apologize excuse me I have to
go to the bathroom you walk away okay
I'm doing better now that's how you deal
with it you understand that I'll teach
you how to deal with it but that's how
you deal with it so it is coming up all
the time it gets pushed up by different
situations in your life and you don't
want to so you're scared of this stuff
coming up and so you resist it you push
it away you fight it you avoid
situations that would make it come up
even if they're totally natural
situations you want to go to the party
yeah okay let's go we gotta do all your
friends together I'm all excited about
it well you know Paul's going to be
there
no
I don't want to go I can't deal I can't
deal with that you can't deal with that
I can't deal with the stuff coming up
that's being pushed up by the Shakti by
the energy I can't deal with it all
right so now you're getting a little
taste of what it really means to work on
yourself
you don't have to do anything in fact if
you would not do anything it'd be fine
all you have to do is not
resist not fight the process not not be
able to handle this natural process of
purification that is going to take place
you don't have to go down there and make
it happen like people write me sometimes
there's a lot of stuff down there how do
I know which one to work with it's right
in front of you
oh but but this isn't my major one I
don't care if you will work with the one
that's coming up now where do you see
what happens and then you're actually
going to see it's perfect
it knows exactly which one needs to come
I'll say am I pulling a string to unwind
a ball of thread that's tied together
you better pull the right string or it
all gets tighter it knows exactly what
needs to come up next and if you can let
go of that one the next thing happens
the next thing happens you don't have to
pay attention
why I'm in this you call it the human
predicament that I keep getting pulled
into all of these disturbances yes well
I love that you use the word dis I would
like to call them distractions instead
of disturbances okay you know it's like
to get distracted we distracted all the
time you're doing something and then
something else catches your attention
correct
that's what has happened in here you are
being distracted by your thoughts
okay you're being distracted by your
emotions you're being distracted what's
coming in by your senses your so
Consciousness is so destructive of these
things that it little identifies with
them it says that's who I am because
that's that's where I'm hanging out I
tell people if I were to stare at a
point let's say the tile on the floor if
all I do is stare at the town on the
floor that's my world
because my world is what I'm conscious
of right okay and so if I focus
completely on something narrow like that
then I've narrowed my Consciousness I
tell everybody in the 60s we felt like
expanding Consciousness I would never
use that term anymore the term is stop
constricting and Contracting your
Consciousness your Consciousness is
already fully expanded my Consciousness
can see this whole room but if I focus
on just a point on the floor then that's
all I'm conscious of so what we're doing
is getting distracted by our thoughts
distracted by our emotions distracted
with what's coming in through our senses
that's a very small part of the universe
to say the least right it's like three
feet by five feet high or six feet high
that that's it it's just a point on the
planet Earth and you know my favorite
saying 1.3 million Earths fit inside the
sun 1.3 million and how much space do
you take up on the earth and your
Consciousness is constantly drawn down
to being distracted and focusing on
these thoughts your thoughts your
emotions and what's coming through your
senses that's miniscule compared to
what's going on everywhere
okay and that's why you get caught down
there that's our predicament that's the
human predicament which is what
Consciousness which I assure you is
capable of experiencing much more than
just staring at yourself
it doesn't have to stare at yourself
whatever if I don't stare at the point
in the floor what do I see everything
else if you don't stare at yourself what
do you see everything else
and that's the great spiritual state but
you're perfectly capable everyone's
perfectly of experiencing that but the
question is how to not be distracted
by our thoughts how to not be distracted
by our emotions more importantly not I
don't like to play how how to not why
are we so distracted by our thoughts how
many thoughts do we have how many of
your thoughts are meaningless how many
thoughts end up being you were stupid to
think it right it just didn't turn out
to be real it didn't turn out to be a
problem didn't know how to the person
wasn't really thinking what you thought
they were thinking he was in a bad mood
you understand that a lot of our
thoughts the vast majority of our
thoughts be better off we didn't have
them they're just distracting our
Consciousness from work from
relationships and so on and so forth so
the question is why are you so
distracted by your thoughts and until
you learn to not be distracted by your
thoughts you're going to be distracted
by your thoughts well you're so
distracted by your emotions
until you learn not to be you're going
to be pulled down at your emotions so
that's the foundation to me that's the
foundation of spirituality surrender is
very very subtle
and very very powerful
and you will find out that it is the
entire spiritual journey
what surrender is
as we've discussed it is
you are under predicament
it's called reality
right now where almost all of us are I'm
leaving the Masters out
is we are conscious
and we are aware of what is unfolding in
front of us
the world is coming in we're
experiencing it
the mind is reacting to the world that's
coming in because we stored reactive
triggers inside ourselves due to our
past experiences the heart is reacting
to the reaction of the Mind
or we have stored so much within our
heart that it's leaking it just comes up
with stuff all by itself it doesn't need
the outside world to come in and
stimulate
this is reality this is what's going on
so you are in there overwhelmed at all
times by this experience of releasing
energies inside of you that most people
know absolutely nothing about and it's
like a drowning person I'm drowning well
while I'm drowning I'm not very nice
well I'm drowning I scream a little bit
while I'm drowning I yell at people help
me help me I do all kinds of things
while I'm drowning if somebody swims to
help me I'll grab them they may drown
too I'm not in charge of my actions I'm
not a rational human being I'm not
centered I'm not clear I'm drowning
and we are drowning inside
so what do you do when you're drowning
you try to grab something solid that's
what you do you try to grab a floating
board passing by you tried to grab
anything you can in order to not sink
that is how almost everybody is living
their lives what are we grabbing you're
trying to grab on to form outside if
people respect me and talk nicely to me
I won't be as as caustic in here if
she'll love me instead of loving him and
pay attention to me and and say nice
things to me and marry me not to mention
marry me like take vows and tell me
She'll always be true to me and so
that's pretty solid all right excuse me
um and you grab a hold of that and you
hold on to it and you try to not drown
until he or she goes out and does
something that doesn't reinforce that
and then you drown right if you want to
see how much you're clinging and Holding
On by trying to to try to create a
solidity inside
via the outside world see what happens
when it's not the way you want I mean
it's like trying to even ask it what
happens when somebody does something
who's very close to you who you have
depended on and are clinging to if you
will all right what happens when they do
something that does not reinforce your
ability to cling they say something or
act something you think they say
something you somebody tells you they
acted something or you think maybe
someday they will even that even if
they've done nothing and your mind
thinks well what if they do Sally's
husband left her what if what if Saul
leaves me that's all it takes isn't it
and what do you feel pain
pain you feel disturbance you feel
destruction all these energies shift
inside that's right because what you
have been doing is trying to build a
place of solidity within your mind that
you can hold on to and as long as
everything reinforces that at least
reasonably you feel you're safe you have
distance yourself from the core of the
energies that you've stored Inside by
clinging to something else that's how we
live that's what we do
one opportunity that always presents
itself constantly in a workplace
is perfecting your interaction with
other people
it's a relationship just like your
personal relationships that you have at
home you have relationships with every
single person you're interacting with
and we need to learn to perfect those
and by perfecting those we'll perfect
ourselves why
what happens naturally as we've
discussed earlier is we've had
experience in our lives
those experiences have carved you
they've carved your sense of good and
bad and and what you like and what you
don't like what you're afraid of and
what you desire Etc these are not things
you decided they're things that your
environment and your experiences left
these Impressions these Impressions got
left on top of you so now what happens
is when you look out into the world what
you see is yourself you know that you've
all heard that before so you look
outside because you're looking through
the glasses of your own personal
experiences everything looks that way
well that's not a good foundation for
working with other people and what
you're going to find out is that you
become very critical of other people so
if you're a boss when you look at other
people you think your employees they
should be doing things the way you
thought the way you do them so what it
comes down to is how do I use my
interaction with the people in my
Workforce in my workplace to perfect
myself so that I learn how to get along
with people that are different than me
the beauty of when you go home there's a
handful of people you know one two three
your family when you go to the workplace
there's lots of people and so you get
this tremendous opportunity
to learn how to work with diversity
people are diverse
so how do I go about working with people
first you start by neutralizing yourself
you realize that your view of how it
should be done what everything is is
just your view so you try to listen to
what other people are trying to say
through their actions about how they
would go about doing it now I can give
you a nice talk about how everybody has
contribution every has something to give
and just give them an opportunity let's
say you're past that and what you see is
that things are not being done in a way
that is constructive or ultimately
constructive or ultimately efficient
you're the boss you're somebody in a
position that's your responsibility to
get things running as good as possible
is even as smooth and effective as
possible efficient as possible so how do
I deal now with a person who's going
about their business and it's not coming
out that way I look at it as an
opportunity to perfect the universe it
is not something against the other
person I'm not criticizing the other
person even Within Myself they're not
doing anything wrong the universe
created them they are the result of
everything that caused them to be the
way they are everything's that way and
I've now been put in a position where I
can help to raise the universe to help
it run more smoothly help it run better
so you start off with a constructive
view that if something is not perfect in
front of you that's a good thing that's
an opportunity for you it doesn't get
you upset doesn't make you frustrated it
doesn't make you angry therefore when
you approach the other person you're not
putting them on a defensive point of
view if you cause defensiveness in
another person you've not done your job
because nobody does good based on
defensive or fear that is not a
foundation for good work so basically
you approach it from the point of view
of that person is me and I have these
blockages I have this inability to see
something how do I work with myself how
do I change this and a lot of times
you'll end up working with a person not
even about the thing that you want to
talk about you start working at another
level with the person and help them work
through what issues they have that are
causing them to be the way they are and
it becomes a friendship it becomes a
beautiful experience you find that your
entire interaction with every single
person in your life is giving you are
serving that's all you're doing it is
your job to help it be the best that it
can be they're not serving you I'm CEO
of accompanied all these people they're
not serving me I'm here to serve them
I'm here to help them be better once you
get comfortable being with reality this
is very deep this is what Lao Sue tried
to talk about in the Dow now that you
are willing to let go of yourself your
personal self and interact with reality
your awareness is now experiencing
reality you will find that there's not
one single moment that unfolds in front
of you that is not calling to you to
interact with it it is there you are
there because you are meant to be with
each other that's how perfect it is it's
like the most perfect relationship
people looking for their soul mates it's
right in front of you it's called life
it is the most perfect fit for your
being that's why you're there and it's
there and you will feel it and you will
know what to do I'm telling you you will
never ever have trouble making a
decision again for the rest of your life
you will never wonder you will never
have any angst or anything it'll just be
the universe it's sort of like listen to
me you're on the ocean on a surfboard
how do you know when to go up and when
to go down you don't the wave does it
for you you just ride the wave the wave
comes up you go up the wave goes down
you go down but what if I want to go
down when it goes up you fall what if I
want to go up when it goes down you fall
it's like you just interjected yourself
into a system that you're supposed to be
in harmony with and if you are in
harmony with it you will know exactly
what to do because it's telling you what
to do is that telling you with words but
it is telling you what to do isn't it
it's telling you what to do it's a go to
the right go to the left feel it be in
harmony with it that's how you ride a
wave that is the Dao that is what laosu
is talking about how you ride life if
you're not busy in there wanting it to
be other than it is then you are in
harmony with what it is the moments know
where they're going they're part of a
Harmony that's moving through time and
space you are here to experience that
and participate in that you don't have
to do anything it is happening to you
you're happening with it and then you're
going to see that what happens you start
just being with it and everyone looks at
you and says oh you're so good at
everything you do you're not doing
anything you're not doing a single thing
but you're neither doing nor not doing
that's the deepest of all the teachings
you are there with it it's doing
something the ocean is doing something
so obviously if you're on the ocean and
the ocean's doing something it looks
like you're doing something seriously
what I just told you is the entire
bhagavad-gita it's the deepest teaching
you will ever even come close to
everyone will think you're doing things
you're not doing a single thing but
you're also not not doing either right
you are just being on the ocean and
being with it and the ocean knows where
it's going therefore you will be the one
who's in harmony with everything it's so
simple that we miss it if you want to
play baseball and you want to pick up a
grounder I do not think that what you
should be doing is guessing where it's
going to go next you should be watching
it why because it knows where it's going
next you see that scene so weird you're
the smart one you should be the one who
can figure it out I guarantee you right
now that ball knows more about where
it's going than you do the ground and
the ball and the interacting with them
those way more about what's going to
happen next than anything you're going
to figure out that's why they say keep
your eye on the ball they don't say keep
your eye on your mind they don't say
that they say keep your eye on the ball
in every sport why because the ball
knows where it's going it just it's the
forces of nature therefore it knows
where it's going it is perfectly in
harmony with all the forces that it's
interacting with isn't it so if you keep
your eye on the ball you have a better
chance of being where it's going because
you're paying attention to where it's
going you're not guessing you're not
figuring you're not using logic you're
not worrying you're not angsting you're
not hoping you're not praying even a
good religious coach if you say coach
when the ball is hit should I close my
eyes and pray that I get it or or should
I watch the ball they're going to tell
you to forget the praying stuff at that
time pray that you can keep your eye on
the ball all right you're supposed to
keep your eye on the ball and it's the
same thing with life I'm telling you
it's exactly the same you come into
harmony with the moments that are
unfolding in front of you well why would
I do that I'm not even gonna answer you
if you're sat here this long because
they are the moments who are sitting in
front of you what if I don't like them
it has nothing to do with like and
dislike does it it has to do with
Dancing with it what if I don't like
what the waves are doing then don't surf
because you're going to fall and it's
the same way with life
I'm here for a little while on the
planet Earth just a very little time a
few years and I get to see I don't get
to see much it's really embarrassing I
only get to see a little tiny bit that's
in front of me and even in a moment I
miss everything else
you understand that those of you think
you know something you don't know
anything
here's a book it's just the most
brilliant book read one word give me the
book back
do you know the book
here's a moment in life there are 700
billion quillion going on at the same
time you saw one you know what's going
on
no you don't know what's going on you
know the slightest idea was going on you
only know what you picked up so I told
you statistically what you picked up is
statistically insignificant
in fact it rounds to zero
Point
am I right or wrong you see it so
therefore what you picked up can't be
anything it's nothing it's zero
but you think it's everything and to you
it is everything because it's the only
thing you picked up it's your Universal
set is like nothing is just God I'm
trying to talk to you intelligently
so the right way to come into the moment
is to sit here and realize I'm a
conscious being that's a blessing
however it came from I don't know but
I'm here I know I'm here and I'm
conscious and there's this moment of
folding in front of me I am well aware
that there are 700 billion zillion going
on everywhere that I'm not experiencing
but I can't do anything about that let
me at least experience the one I'm
experiencing wow it's kind of neat let
me at least experience what I'm
experiencing like a gift this is the
gift that's being given to you there's
another gift being given to everybody
else there's seven billion people on the
planet Earth every single one of them
experience something different every
single moment
that's what they're experiencing that's
the gift that's being given to them and
so you actually come into the moment I'm
afraid to say it with a sense of Honor
with a sense of respect with a sense of
gratitude you sit there and say to the
moment
wow thank you this is the one I got to
experience
has nothing to do with what I want what
I don't want and what should be or
shouldn't be it has to do with my
humility of realizing I'm not the
creator of the universe I am the
experiencer of this moment that's what I
am there are forces that are creating
the universe you do know that you want
to call them science I love him I want
to call it God I love it it makes no
difference just call it not me
that's the nicest name for the creator
of the universe not me because you know
it's not you don't you okay you just
gotta sit in here picking up the moment
that's in front of you then honor and
respect that experience your will now
you listen to me your will
and I remember your will your will you
in there okay the power you have is
stronger than any force that can ever
distract you or do anything to you
period you are the strongest thing in
there will is the power of self it is
the power of conscious energy when an
event happens outside and the
Consciousness starts to get drawn toward
it you have every ability to relax and
bring it back
every one of you do don't tell me I
don't know I'm a very strong will the
fact that you took human birth means
that your will and your soul is evolved
enough to be Transcendent to every
single force that can draw on it did you
know that
that's why people can do weird things
you know people do all kinds of weird
things like Yakuza I need to tell you
this if they insult their Master they
sit there and it's Japanese how am I
telling you this I don't know because
I'm showing you I'm showing you how
powerful will is right and they sit
before their master and their boss and
they say I'm so sorry how sorry I am
they take a knife they put their finger
down and they cut their finger off while
they're talking and looking and staring
at that and they they ceremonially could
batch up their finger and give it give
the finger in a rap club this is true
right it's true statement and a rap
class they give it to the to their boss
their Master they had a mafia that kind
of thing right to sit there and say
that's how sorry I am that I didn't live
up to your expectations all right
there's a lot of Yakuza running around
with that they leave their trigger
finger last because they're Mafia right
yeah
I'm in trouble
all right but what I'm trying to show
you is that's a lot of will
that's painful that's serious okay right
people do all kinds of things because
they want to they want to enough to
where their will is strong enough that
they can apply it you want out
see you're Yakuza but for a different
reason right you're a great being you
want liberation
you don't remember what it's like don't
have like garbage going on inside of you
are you willing when you get
Consciousness awareness that the moment
you see it's about to get pulled over
here or over here
are you willing to relax are you willing
to just relax you let it go God I always
explain it this way people think you
have to be strong to do this you do not
have to be strong to do this this is not
a question of strength what do you do if
you can't stay centered when you go to
visit your parents
some people that way right you go to
visit your parents and you're fine you
did find and you go and somehow you just
can't hold it together and you find
yourself falling back into your old
patterns and getting the arguments and
doing these things all right what do you
do you work on it you literally Center
yourself before you walk into that room
that's what you do and you breathe just
within yourself and then you see how
long you can sit there
without opening your mouth
how many things can get said to you
without you saying things back and then
you try to see why is it so hard
to not get sucked in
like you just do what you need to do to
watch and then you'll notice inside
yourself
deep stuff that you never noticed before
insecurities and fears and resentments
and things that you stored inside of you
that these people stimulate and you
can't handle those things and that's why
you can't handle the people
and you keep staying centered and you
let that be the purpose of your life
and then when these things come up you
let them go
and all of a sudden going home to visit
mom and dad is a spiritual experience
all of a sudden meeting your ex is a
spiritual experience all of a sudden all
of these things that you thought were so
disturbing that you didn't want to
happen the fact that they can still get
to you
means you have work in that area and you
just decide to do that work because you
have a choice anyways that's what I
think is funny no I'm not going to do
that work okay suffer you either use it
to liberate you or you suffer it is
either leading you to a higher state of
consciousness and freedom and
exhilaration and openness or you suffer
with it and that is your choice and so
you do this work and you're just little
by little stay conscious let go stay
conscious I told you in the end and you
might as well make it in the beginning
because in the end it is not a mental
thing
it is not an emotional thing it is as
false you notice that the energy is
starting to get Disturbed
before you figure out why don't even
think about it just relax your shoulders
relax your chest relax your stomach and
let go
it is always highest thing you can do
to harmonize with the moment that is
unfolding in front of you that goes for
business goes for relationships goes for
sports it goes for children so many
people make it so anxious to bring up a
child oh my God what do I need to do oh
it's the most natural thing in the world
be present in the moment with each stage
the child is going through and bring
your best game
not for you but I wanted to be a lawyer
I was never announced you dare do that
you come into the moment with the child
and you try to hear what they're saying
you tried to see what they're going
through and you tried to see how you can
raise that moment to the best of your
ability that's all you can do that's the
highest thing you can do and it will end
up with the highest results that could
possibly happen you need to worry about
it you need to think about it you don't
need to feel guilty you don't need to
feel shame nothing you're just in the
current moment you bring your best game
what's your best game it starts with
honoring and respecting the moment
that's in front of you period not just
accepting that's not even enough loving
gratitude I could be experiencing
nothing
somebody said to me the other day that I
remembered I said this how much of the
universe is blank empty space
99.99999 do you understand that because
all there is out there is blank empty
space
you do know that don't you you know I
think our nearest star Alpha Proxima
whatever it is this is what was it 4.5
light years away the nearest star
nothing in between 4.5 light years away
and how far away that is if I caught a
light beam and held it above the Earth
if I let it go for one second
it's just circumnavigated the Earth
eight times
oh it's a little faster do that every
single second for 4.5 years and you'll
get to the next star
the next galaxy is 2.4 million light
years away so I mean there's nothing but
empty space everywhere
and you get to have this in front of you
that's just interesting color shapes
things so but I taught the person
repeated it to me last night is instead
of comparing what is going on in front
of you against what you want what you
made up based on your past compare it
against nothing
feel gratitude I am grateful that I get
to have this experience and be that way
with every single moment in your life
that's the highest life you can live in
it that's the highest life you can live
and you'll stop storing stuff inside of
you because you'll stop saying I don't
want this
it's all exciting it's all challenging
I'm willing to go through anything it's
just a challenging experience it's a fun
thing and you'll become empty inside and
that becomes your spiritual growth also
as you start to embrace the moments in
front of you with the whole of your
being you become empty you become pure
and all this Energy starts to well up
inside of you
for our next foray into how to bring
spirituality into the workplace and make
the workplace spiritual
this is something we ran into I was in
program design for the medical industry
and so sometimes we'd have projects
given to us where they wouldn't be
defined at all they'd just be oh I know
how to keep my medical records in the
computer
could mean a million different things it
was early in the game when no one was
computerized medical records
or appointment scheduling what does it
mean what are the criteria there were no
specifications
so there are times when you are given a
project that you literally don't know
what to do it's just that simple it's
not that you're blocked is that you
haven't had the experience there isn't
someone to turn to that has had the
experience
so you bring a team together and no one
in that team knows what to do so that
brings up a really interesting teaching
of how to work spiritually and how the
benefits of all the Deep Eastern
teachings can come into the workplace
what we used to do in a situation like
that is they bring my team together
six or seven people would sit around all
very very high level developers and the
first criteria that I would work with is
are you all willing to admit you don't
have an answer you don't know and I'm
their boss they don't like saying that
but you have to start with reality
otherwise somebody's walking into that
room thinking they're supposed to have
an answer they don't but they made
something up that is noise that just
creates tremendous trouble in the
workplace in a meeting in this creative
environment all right that somebody
thinks they know but what they really
know is I want to know and I want to
impress everybody and I'm afraid of not
knowing so it's just ego garbage and so
you don't want to bring that into the
meeting so what do you do how do you
start everybody's sitting there
admitting I don't know
so what I learned to do and what I
taught them I called it the yin yang
method of design of solving problems
that you have the answers to
you don't know how to start so let's
start somewhere you start with asking
the question well what's the minimum
that I could do it's not the right
answer we're not going to do it nobody's
justifying it but what is the minimum
that we could do and claim that it
satisfied this project that we've been
given and you talk about it don't design
it don't get down to detail because
we're not going to stay there you just
get a feeling of what's right about the
minimum what's wrong about the minimum
and all of a sudden you know about this
you know why that's not enough you can
get passionate about it you know why it
won't solve this problem or that problem
or satisfy one of your clients right and
you know why you have to release that we
can't go lower than that right because
it doesn't do anything and all of a
sudden you're having a fruitful engaged
beautiful discussion where a minute ago
everybody was saying I don't know
anything and all of a sudden you're like
you do know something you do know what
the minimum looks like so you start with
that but you don't design it you don't
get down to oh what will we do what will
look like no no no just talk about what
the pros and cons of this being the
minimum find the minimum find the lower
Edge then immediately once you put that
to rest for a moment don't let anybody
Buy in don't say oh I think that's right
I'm not interested this is not about
what you like make it or don't like it
it's about admitting this is the least
we could do and here's the pros and cons
of that then go to the expansive what's
the most you could do what's the most
you can do there is a most you could do
you know it could take you three years
to do it but given that situation that
you're talking about just let your mind
go what is the most that you could do
you know going beyond that would be
ridiculous there'd be no way you'd need
to there'd be no way you'd want to what
is the outer edge of what this project
could look like all right if you're
really just expanded it into what's the
most it could mean the main obstacle is
the unwillingness to experience what it
feels like to go through withdrawal what
is the obstacle for a person getting off
of hard drugs or getting off of alcohol
they could be very committed they said I
want to do it right but there is that
tendency that you have habits you have
you have Tendencies and to let these go
require a certain amount of commitment
and a certain amount of strength a
center of will that I really am
committed to this and then you go
through this process of withdrawal this
process of purification it isn't
comfortable but you have to want the
result more than you're afraid of the
discomfort so I always tell people it's
not about whether you like something or
not it's a question whether you can
handle it don't ask yourself do I like
this or not ask yourself can I handle
this and it's a rhetorical question
because you better be able to because
the alternative to be able to handle
something is you can't handle it and I
don't want to be around nor do you right
so you just that we talk about that
Center of will that Center of volition
you sit in there and realize I got drunk
inside of me I've developed patterns
that are not healthy just like drugs I
mean I'm not saying that you're doing
drugs right but it's it's like a drug
it's like alcohol you have these
patterns of reactions that are just got
formed inside of you when you weren't
paying attention and now you need to let
them go so the obstacle is your
unwillingness to go through what it
takes to Let It Go the moment you decide
I want out I want to let this go and
there's two reasons to let it go one is
the non-negative because it sure cause
you a lot of trouble all that noise in
there and the other is the positives
both are fine I want to let it go
because I want to have a reasonable life
I want to let it go because I want to
have one life to live I want to
experience the highest I can possibly
experience I want to explore the depth
of my being I want to know what Christ
meant when he said my father and I are
one I want to know where Buddha went
with Nirvana whatever level you feel the
positive right and both of those The
Inspirations are non-negative and the
inspiration of the positive should give
you the drive the the inspiration the
intention that you need in order to say
I'm Letting Go I'm letting go because
the alternative is absurd the
alternative is to give my life to the
lowest part of my being the highest life
you can live is that every moment that
passed in front of you is better off
because it did
every moment because it passed in front
of you you interacted with a way that
when it went on its way it was higher
than before it passed before you
as Saint Francis and prayers and make me
an instrument of thy peace where there's
sickness when we bring Health where
there's sadness let me bring joy not let
me take from the moment when you're when
you're not okay inside you're taking you
need you're taking when you're okay
inside you're giving to the moment
you're raising the moment not according
to what you think should be happening in
accordance to what you're hearing the
moment bring to you it talks to you
that's not mystical if there are storm
clouds up ahead and you see sheets of
rain in a distance life is telling you
it is probably going to rain where you
are
that's literally Christ said let those
have eyes to see let them see let those
over ears to hear Let Them hear in other
words come on get out of your head
and pay attention to what's going on in
front of you that's all you need to do
that's all you need to do it will tell
you everything you need it'll give you
an idea where it's going give you an
idea where it's coming from give you an
idea what it needs on this journey and
you become a servant you become a
servant of the moment that's in front of
you and then you let it go let it go how
many of you have conversations with
somebody and then when the conversation
is over and you walk away the
conversation's not over inside your head
oh I shouldn't have said oh I've only
had said this oh my God oh my God you
probably think that's so stupid I should
call him no don't call him you're really
stupid
what is that you're missing the next
moment because you're being neurotic
about the last one so you can't possibly
be doing the best you can do you
understand that because there's
literally a moment unfolding in front of
you while you're doing that you're
obviously missing that moment aren't you
because you're caught in the last one
you should have the ability to have a
conversation be present in the
conversation absolutely do the best that
you can in that conversation to raise it
and if it's business you can raise it
for you know to do the best in business
if it's a relation we raise it best for
love nobody's saying you're not
interacting with it in harmony with its
purpose but basically when it's over I'm
telling it's over all that stuff you do
of causing yourself a hard time and
building all that junk inside that's not
helping doesn't help a while it just
makes it more neurotic
so basically you let go then you come
present the next moment and you just
live in the harmony of the moment you
give yourself to it that is what loud
Sue meant by the Dao and he ever studied
the Dao he called it the way the way the
way of life the way of that is all of
Zen that is all of everything it's all
the martial arts it's all the sports why
do you think they teach football players
and other people to meditate it's
because this state of openness this
state of harmony with what's going on
we'll give you that edge instead of
being caught on your mind
so life is beautiful
now I will tell you that all of Life is
Beautiful birth is Beautiful Death is
beautiful everything's beautiful except
that you make it not be beautiful
because you've made up how you want it
to be your house is beautiful you don't
want to makes it not beautiful because
you think it's not big enough because
you wish the color would change because
you know The Neighbor Next Door got a
nicer one Everything Is Beautiful if you
interact with it with a sense of respect
with a sense of Honor with a sense of
being and what is amazing that if you do
that I don't even know how to talk about
the purpose of my second book The
certain experiment was that somehow just
by doing that what unfolds is way higher
than anything you could ever do how
important is the slowing down or the
relaxation I think of relaxation I for
me I think I've got to slow it down when
it slows down it doesn't have the bite
it doesn't have the power I'm able to
become the witness
how do you slow it down and is that an
important part of it or not in your
experience I don't any longer have to
slow it down it's it's like learning to
walk because I learned to ride a bike
you have to take your different stages
right so first and in the book there's a
chapter called Oprah said it was her
favorite chapter it's called let go now
or fall yes the moment is very much what
you were telling the moment you see like
anger doesn't happen all at once it
starts like it starts down there that's
when you have to deal with it yeah
sincere enough to say I don't even want
to know what I'm about to get angry
about yes I know that that's not a part
of my being I need to listen to All
right so when it starts you relax right
it's that commitment to relax and relax
your shoulders relax your chest relax
your tummy it doesn't take time there's
nothing there's nothing you have to put
aside time to do this yeah right you
just have to be conscious be committed
right so you relax it and you lean away
you just lean away from the noise right
and you actually don't realize that at
first it feels good because you didn't
get angry you didn't get all involved or
neurotic or whatever it was right and
react but you're actually leaning into a
deeper part of your being when you lean
away from the lower part of your being
right and I want to do one little thing
because a lot of your people are very
successful obviously they work with you
so they get successful right and I often
have people say to me I don't want to
give up the fear I don't want to give
the anger it's what drives me it's what
I use come on yeah you know they say
that yeah it's what I use to be
successful right if I give that up why
would I get out of bed in the morning
they actually ask that right and what
what you're missing is for one thing
there are lots of things you can use
drugs all kinds of things please don't
all right that temporarily or
momentarily can give you some energy
right but they will destroy you anger
will destroy you fear will destroy you
they burn out your adrenals they burn
out your system so it's not a long-term
solution and this question of if I don't
have that to drive me why would anything
drive me right have you ever fallen love
who's ever fallen in love do you find
that you're driven to be with the person
do you find you want to get things for
him or her do you find right yes love is
a motivator way greater than fear or or
anxiety or or any of that kind of pain
you know the anger love motivates you to
give and express itself love wants to
express itself so what happens is when
you let go of this lower stuff you'll
start noticing love starts to come up
you're starting to open up to the higher
energies there are so many situations in
our everyday experiences of work that
are just excellent opportunities for
growth
so for example you find yourself in a
meeting and there's a group of people
and they're sharing ideas and their
views
the first thing I want to talk about is
if you watch
what you're going to realize is you're
not really listening
you're doing one of two things and this
goes even not just for meetings just
even in conversations when you just sit
there talking to somebody
either when they're talking and you're
supposedly listening what you're
actually listening to is your own view
of what they're saying you're listening
to the voice inside your head say well I
never did anything like that I wonder
why yeah I wouldn't want that to happen
to me either and no no I wouldn't say it
the way you said it I would but and
you're in there talking the voice inside
your head is talking and you're actually
paying as much if not more attention to
your opinion view judgment whatever it
is extensions add-ons and subtractions
to what's being said then you are paying
attention to the words coming out of the
person's mouth and that's if you're
actually listening what happens very
often in a meeting and I see it all the
time with people all right is they're
not even listening to anybody saying
they're thinking about what they're
going to say when it's their turn that's
all that's going on inside their head is
they're just thinking about how do I
formulate that's unbelievable I
shouldn't even have to talk on that if
you're doing that you don't belong in
the meeting because the purpose of the
meeting is we're all different
we're all different we all have
different stuff inside of our heads
because we've all had different
experiences in life we've all had
different experiences and we've
processed them different ways therefore
the data that we have for the foundation
of our thoughts is completely different
than everybody else in that room even if
you worked together for 20 years still
your background your upbringing what
happened outside of work all of these
things formulate the way you think so
when you walk into a room with a meeting
you understand that what you have is a
whole bunch of data sets and every one
of those data sets is correct there's
not one of them that's more correct than
the other if I look out a window
everybody looks out the window but looks
at different angles there's nobody who's
seeing it right or they're just seeing
what's out there is bigger than any one
thing you can see so no person has gone
through life experiencing what's there
all the experience of what was in front
of them from moment to moment so
therefore everybody is right everybody
has a different experience of life
therefore everybody has something to
contribute if you are open if you are
present if you bring Consciousness to
Bear you are better at every single
thing you do you understand that
including relationships and finances and
every single thing it's not just sitting
in a corner and trying to enter some
higher state of consciousness bring your
awareness of being into the current
moment and be present
sounds good but to me those are just
words and it doesn't really come all the
way home so I'd like to start with an
example
because we're not the first people to
use the word mindfulness
it has been used in the American English
language for a very long time
let's say you're driving driving is an
excellent example of how we can
understand mindfulness
when you are driving
there are traffic lights and I don't
know if you notice but they change
sometimes and it is really important
that you know that
did you get it all right and and also in
front of you there are other drivers I
hope you notice that and they sometimes
step under brakes and these red lights
come on in the back of the car it's very
important that you notice that I'm this
is mindfulness
it's best that you be mindful when
you're driving when you go to change
lanes are you aware that even if you
look in your mirrors that there's a
thing called a blind spot
you best be mindful of that so if
somebody's teaching you how to drive
they might use that word be mindful of
all times of what's going on around you
that is mindfulness too all right and it
is exactly what we mean
by being present in the moment and
bringing Consciousness to Bear all right
that's kind of neat isn't it so you
really do know about mindfulness what
happens if you're driving and you're not
mindful
you crash
very very quickly all right aside from
the fact that there are lights there are
other cars there are blind spots there
are these things called Curves in the
road it best be that you know that
that's funny but you understand what I'm
saying if you don't pay attention to
this if you are not present when you are
driving it will not take 10 seconds
before you crash do you understand that
you are not I mean forget about this you
know texting and so on right I'm just
talking about if you're not mindful
or sometimes I say to people let's say
you're driving and somebody cuts you off
all right which is really important when
we start about mindfulness it's best
that you notice it
all right now you're being asked to
interact you're being asked to be
present
and be present enough to decide what to
do what are your actions
I will ask you is the is the amount of
mindfulness that you bring to your
driving going to affect the quality of
your driving how many tickets you get
how many accidents you get in and how
well you do let's say you're a Race Car
Driver
could you use the amount of mindfulness
that you bring to driving
for driving at Daytona at you know 180
200 miles an hour with 15 cars passing
you and the answer is no you better not
okay you best bring a lot more
mindfulness to the presence and what
that means as a race car driver right is
that hopefully there is nothing else
going on you're not thinking about the
fight you had with the wife you're not
worrying about this or that you had best
bring your Consciousness to bear in what
you are doing or you are in big trouble
all right but it's not just in driving
because I'm going to put that aside in
that particular case if you do not be
mindful you're in trouble not just as a
race car driver that's required more so
the more Prof and then I'll argue that
the more professional you get and the
better you want to do the more
mindfulness you better bring to bear
whether you're talking about sports
whether you're talking about driving
right the more Consciousness you bring
to bear I like that term right I can use
it because we're using examples isn't
that bringing Consciousness to bear in
the current moment the more
Consciousness you bring to bear in the
current current moment the better you
are what you're doing anybody argue that
right just take the extremes don't bring
any let go of yourself
let go of yourself this thing you call
yourself your preferences your desires
your needs your bucket list and so on is
just a projection of the stuff you
stored inside but what do you mean if
you didn't have it you'd be filled with
love and filled with light you wouldn't
be asking any questions you'd love
having a child you'd love bring it up
you'd enjoy every moment of it if you
homeschool you don't homeschool doesn't
make any difference everything because
you're fine and that's the environment
they grow up how does I grew up in an
environment where it's just pure love
and openness and understanding and they
have a problem they bring it to you you
don't say oh my God what did I do what's
it you just you have Clarity you can
share with them and help them come to
the solution themselves right yeah so
it's a healthy thing because you're
healthy so a parent shouldn't sit there
and say it's so hard to bring to a child
it's hard because you didn't bring
yourself up you didn't let go of your
own stuff right yeah so it's it's
there's so many things to learn yeah
it's all about you evolving as a being
as a being of light as a being of energy
and keep bringing yourself up and
letting go then you spread that light
everywhere and takes care of business
somebody wanted me to because I did
business at all the business can you
give us spiritual talk on business right
I generally will say no I I don't want
to focus like like that right but the
truth is I would give the exact same
talk right how do you run a sense of
business let go of yourself then you're
not making decisions based on your
garbage and your fears in your past
experiences and all that kind of junk
you're bringing good energy into it and
it will attract good energy and people
around you will work with good energy
and they'll enjoy working with you yeah
my company we're technical high-tech
very few people ever left they loved
working there yeah right and I didn't
pay him the top salaries either because
we're out here in the middle of the
woods right and basically you just
create an environment for business an
environment for children environment for
love an environment for everything you
do that brings Beauty and love and
Clarity and selflessness true
selflessness into your environment it
will change everything what is love
Shakti the energy rising up to the
fourth chakra and pouring out the foot
chakra that's what you call love and to
cut the tuning with somebody who you
like if if they talk the way you want to
dress the way you want act the way you
want Etc et cetera you open and then the
energy can come up and you feel this
experience of love but what if you're
not closed what if you never close
that is all love you know it should take
for you to feel love anytime you want
just wave your hand in front of your
heart and Bliss pours through your heart
all the time anytime you want that is
what it means to reach a state of
Happiness a state of pure unconditional
happiness it's inside of you it's
available to you anything the challenges
of life are amazing what's wrong with
challenges we play sports we like
challenges nobody wants to play a team
that you beat 700 to 1 every time you
play them you want to be challenged you
want to have to bring out the best of
your being
if you can get clean inside where you're
not being run by all these past
Impressions we call them some scars in
yoga of all these past Impressions which
are telling you and they are telling you
constantly you can only be happy if this
happens and you can never be happy if it
doesn't and you will never be happy if
such as it happens and then you go out
into the world chasing this
as opposed to working inside on yourself
to say I don't need those conditions
life is amazing I'm sitting on a planet
spitting in the middle of nowheres and
there's all these events happening don't
worry they won't last you're not going
to stay here but while you're here do
you want to run around and fight with
life and people and places and things
and even the weather to try to make it
be what you think you want
or do you want to work on yourself to
clean up this mess inside so you can be
open all the time that's what
spirituality is about it's not about
pronunciation it's pronunciation is too
late you've already decided that you
want something you need it to be happy
but you're not going to do it depth
spirituality is understanding you don't
need anything
you don't need anything doesn't mean you
don't do anything but you don't need
anything you're a whole and complete
within yourself if you open there is
tremendous Joy love inspiration that
Wells up inside you the moment you open
the moment something happens that you
like watch how fast you feel Joy and if
something happens you don't like watch
how fast you close that is not teaching
you about the outside that's teaching
about the inside
that openness is where it's at closeness
is not openness is what you really want
because what does opening mean it's like
opening the blinds if you close the
blinds in your house your house is dark
it's like that chapter in the untouched
Soul take down the Walls if you close
the blinds in your house your house is
dark now you have to run around with
artificial light trying to figure out
how to get some light if you open the
blinds you don't have to do anything the
light is coming in but you won't open
the blinds until you're sure nobody's
out there and only the right people are
in your house and everything's exactly
what you want you're afraid to open the
binds you don't feel comfortable so you
either decide to spend your life trying
to build artificial light inside or you
decide to work on yourself so you want
to leave the blinds open yoga true
spirituality is about taking off the
blinds take them off the windowsill
throw them out and never ever close them
ever again what is the purpose of
closing it makes you sad it makes you
dark what is depression total darkness
total closeness you have closed off to
the flow of the energy there is no
reason for that there is no excuse for
that this is your world inside it's your
mind it's your heart it is your
responsibility to not close it how dare
you think you're going to meet somebody
who will overcome your tendency to close
I want a job don't give me that job
you're going to know your whole life
building all these Impressions that
bother you or scare you and turn you on
and then you say to me as a relationship
that it's my responsibility to keep your
mind open and your heart open when
you're in there closing it all the time
I hope that seems silly and
counterproductive it is your
responsibility to keep your mind open it
is your responsibility to keep your
heart open and once you learn to do that
they're your mind and your heart once
you learn to do that you will feel Joy
all the time and I mean all the time
from the moment you wake up in the
morning you'll be inspired you'll love
to go to work even if you went to the
same job for 30 years you don't ever get
bored why because just energy flowing up
inside of you you will get the most out
of your relationships you'll be able to
give the most to all moments that are
fully in front of you why because now
you're a giver instead of a taker when
we come into the mall into interaction
with the moments in front of us we're
looking to see what we can get we're
looking to see how we want them to be
we're speaking to change things we're
dressing certain ways we're doing all
kinds of things to manipulate the
moments so that they will be the way we
want and when they come inside they'll
turn us on a being who has learned to be
open all the time never does that they
don't need to do that because they're
already feeling what they want to feel
they're feeling Joy they're feeling love
they're feeling inspiration
so now when the momentum Falls in front
of them they can give to it they can
take this joy and love that they have
and they can then shine it upon the
moment people place them things are
unfolding there's always a voice in my
mind oh I'm crazy like I'm doing
something that's wrong I'm going to be a
gigantic failure like you know people
will look at your laugh at you and all
that but I think those voices are I mean
you talked about actually in all three
books about the preferences and things
you like the how our mind works
um I think it's pretty common yeah have
you had those voices and how did you
deal with this voice well and I
explained in the beginning of the
surrender experiment yeah that's how I
started my spiritual journey is I was
sitting on the couch with a friend of
mine back in who knows 69 70 maybe and
uh there was a lull in the conversation
and
somehow that's not comfortable even with
friends you know that you were talking
then there's nothing to say and you try
to think of things to say to keep keep
the conversation go into the
conversation feeling comfortable yeah
it's really about control right you have
a certain amount of control that you
know this person is interacting with you
they're okay you know what I'm talking
about all right yeah and so I noticed
that that was going on inside my head
that he was anxious even with a friend
all right that there was this sense of
discomfort in the silence yeah and
Mickey Michael was trying to think what
to say to this day I was 52 years ago I
remember the whole exact moment or where
it is and he's sitting there saying uh
it's kind of hot out isn't it or would
you like to get something to eat maybe
we get a pizza Jesse he kept saying
these things yeah and inside I noticed
that that's going on in my mind they all
seem very stupid to say and I didn't
save them for the first time in my life
I didn't go along with that was that the
mind was saying and then I realized uh
who am I that is noticing the mind
saying that and as simple and silly that
seems that guided the rest of my life
period that moment woke me up to realize
wait a minute it's always talking
right as I was trying to figure out
whether to eat or something it's always
saying something it's busy judging and
thinking and liking and not liking and
figuring out what to do yeah but now I'm
not it I'm watching it do that yeah
right Awakening to witness Consciousness
but I had no background I had never met
anybody yeah
nothing yeah nothing yeah it just
happened okay and I'm watching it and I
started to feel I don't want to be that
I don't want to be like that yeah right
yeah and so I remember the first thing I
said instead of do you want to do this
should we do this so I'm watching this
voice inside my head telling me what to
say but I'm feeling distant from it for
the first time in my life and so instead
of saying when I finally talked I didn't
say where do you want to go what do you
want to do isn't it hot you know do you
remember what Nixon did the other day or
something I sat there and said I have
this voice inside my head talking do you
have one and as I said to him and he was
a famous lawyer he was my brother-in-law
at the time and he was a big lawyer in
Chicago and they never thought about
these kind of things and basically he
looked at me and he looked at me strange
with this kind of look and then all of a
sudden bam this light went on in his
eyes it was so beautiful a light when I
said yeah I know just what you're
talking about my my never shuts up and
there it was that was and the rest of
all my years I mean it stopped so I
don't have to work with as much but
everything was about that voice yeah
right so you're talking about how yours
was telling you you can't do this my
whole thing from that moment forward was
wait a minute I don't need this Chunk on
the side of my head yeah it's so
distracting it's so negative it tends to
be negative right and so on so by the
time I was building the house I had
started to work with that voice and this
I started working with him to shut up
shut up shut up I don't want to talk to
you right then you realize that's the
voice telling the voice to shut up yeah
it took it took quite a while for me to
wake up to realize how to work with that
right but at that time I was not
listening to it if it said you can't
build that house I said shut up
which is not the right way do not do the
president that is not the right way to
deal with that voice in your head all
right but so it wasn't a problem because
I wasn't listening to it yeah so I was
just letting this unfold as it was
happening yeah
and putting my whole heart and soul into
this is what I need to do to get to
where I want to go right so I'm going to
do it yeah there's no complaining no
this no that yeah so that's the answer
you start by honoring respecting and
accepting the blessing and the reality
and the right of what is unfolding in
front of you if you don't like it you
look at that it's disharmonious you let
go of yourself and that's Christ said
you must die to be Reborns we're talking
about you literally do the process don't
get mad at yourself for being a certain
way just don't participate in that part
of your being you don't have to get mad
at your hand because it wants to pick up
a cigarette just don't pick up the
cigarette in fact if you get mad at your
hand you'll probably be so stressful you
will pick up the cigarette then you
definitely need a cigarette the same
thing with drinking just don't do it
don't get mad don't do anything just
don't participate in the process that
will not take you where you want to go
so if you find yourself make up an
alternate reality I'm begging you to
just let it go if you find yourself not
liking the reality it's unfolding in
front of you I am begging you relax and
let go all right that's not the end of
your relationship with life that's the
beginning of your relationship with life
the world has its ebb and flows it has
its cycle and it should have its cycles
and you do not understand those cycles
and you will never understand those
Cycles how could you possibly you only
see this tiny bit of life it's a hole
its Cycles are in harmony with its
Universal self you only see the way when
it passes by you say oh I shouldn't be
doing that why because it messed up my
face and her reflection that's why
you'll always do it in relationship to
you you want to know how wrong you are
every single time you say something's
good or bad or right or wrong or better
or worse or preferred or not preferred
I'm going to ask you based on what
everyone else needs a relative term good
bad right wrong preferred not preferred
those are relative terms she doesn't
agree she doesn't agree everyone's got
their own thing don't they they're
relative and I'm going to ask you based
on what and if you're honest you're
going to say based on Me based on my
view of the world based on my value
system so what who cares about your
value system there's narcissus again
there you are looking into the universe
and seeing the reflection of yourself
and saying that's what Matt better so
it's you just get to the point where you
stop putting so much weight on yourself
stop being narcissistic your face is
just one of 700 billion things in the
universe your spiritual journey is about
ceasing to think that you matter it is
about ceasing to think that you are the
center of your Universe the universe is
the center of the universe it's about
Lake not about face it just keeps coming
back to the same thing you have to wake
up to that so your spiritual growth is
not about getting into yourself or
changing your views or duh you need to
go in there and mess around with your
mind is crazy your mind doesn't matter
it's a nothing you know how long it
takes to erase a hard disk just take a
good magnet pass it across it's gone so
it's just meaningless what you have in
there stop rearranging the darn thing
what matters is life itself God the
universal get to know her how by ceasing
to be so interested in yourself so when
you look into the lake of life and
that's what you're doing every minute of
every day you understand that you're
looking into the lake of life when you
look into the lake of life will you
please stop seeing yourself there's lots
and lots and lots of things out there
stop seeing yourself how do I know that
I'm seeing myself I will give you the
biggest clue It Ever Was it offends you
you feel a change in the force in the
energy in the Shakti flow sometimes you
do don't you like lots of times if you
look out into this Lake of life and it
causes a change in the flow of the chi
inside of you you have projected
yourself into life and it hits your
projection I want this to happen I want
that to happen the cause of suffering is
desires Buddha it's all the same
teaching you are projecting from inside
out therefore the innocence of life is
hitting your projections causing you to
suffer causing change to happen inside
your he's just disturbing the peace you
want to stop that you want to find true
spirituality you have to let go of
projecting yourself onto life
why don't we deal with it exactly the
same insides as we deal with it outside
and just sit there and say yes there are
experience in life that are not pleasant
good I like to learn from them doesn't
mean I want to have them I'm not praying
for them right but if they happen to
present themselves in front of me this
is my opportunity to become a greater
being to be able to handle the reality
of life
there
and so that's also the thorn you talk
about right that you can carry you let
it go let things go yeah instead of
compensating for them and learning how
to be okay that it's there it's only
there because inside
there are no Thorns there's no physical
being it's a theoric inside it's
completely open okay how hard is your
future change your mind
later on right okay there's nothing in
there it's just
totally empty right it's just loose
right it's looser than the clouds so why
not make it nice in there so if
something comes in and it's disturbing
yeah I always tell people if you went
through a traumatic terrible experience
when you were young I wish I could go
down there and beat the people up and go
back in time and protect you oh I would
love to do that but I can't I can't and
you can't either nor can anybody else
right so I will blame
person who mistreated you or did this
thing to you when you were five years
old your innocent child right for
causing the Trump that problem then but
they stopped
they went away they moved they died you
know rest I don't care it's whatever
it's over right but you didn't let it be
over for the next 30 Years you did it
I have to blame you for those 30 years I
can't blame them they're not there
I can't believe the experience is not
even happening how dare you blame the
experience that happened 25 years ago
you are the one who chose to keep that
inside of you and let it destroy your
life ooh
I always teach this
first let go then if it's still there
deal with it you're going to find out
that 95 of the time once you relax and
let go there's nothing left to deal with
If somebody walks up you say hey Sally
how are you doing she doesn't turn
around and say hello she's your friend
okay there's there's an experience it's
not comfortable what's wrong why
shouldn't you know blah blah did she not
hear me all that stuff goes on right
relax through it relax through it okay
okay fine that's what happened now what
are you gonna do about it nothing she's
not there anymore there's nothing to do
right and you're crazy it's the next
time you see something why didn't you
say that
you won't do that because you handled it
there's no reason to say anything what a
nice person you are maybe she didn't
hear you maybe she's in a bad mood who
cares
right so if you are willing to let go
you're going to find out the vast
majority of the time there is nothing to
do about it except let go if I go
backwards I I can see that awareness at
age five but then as I get younger and
younger I start to lose track and I
don't know what that was before I was
born and I don't know if that will
continue after I die and so This Promise
of spirituality you'll get to know the
the who inside I'm like okay I kind of
know that who while I'm alive but I
don't know what it will be like when I'm
not alive so I want to know what you
have to say to them I I I'm glad you
don't know and I'm glad you admit that
you don't know because the truth is
almost nobody knows like they believe
and I don't participate in that game I
don't want to just be another person who
tells you to believe something this is
what I'll tell you and I know I'm right
you'll find out
that's as far as you should go with I
don't know whether I'll be there after I
die I guarantee you will find out and if
you're not there it won't be a problem
it's not like I'm not here oh my God I
don't like this no you're not there if
you are there which by the way you will
be but I didn't say that okay you'll
find out what it's like to be there and
not have a body and what's going on
where am I why think about it now live
your life now
be here now all right you'll have that
experience then the fact that you didn't
know what you were like before you
dropped down every Master teaches the
really the same truth which is when you
drop you're gonna say it like this when
you drop into the body when the
Consciousness drops into the body that
is a traumatic experience okay all of a
sudden there's all these Sensations and
all this sound and all these sites and
all these feelings and things it it's
freaky okay the Consciousness totally
freaks out and so it's lost it's called
The Lost Consciousness it it's not like
now I don't care if you think you have
problems you know problems compared to
someone as Amnesia and just woke up from
Amnesia and doesn't know who they are or
where they were understanding that's
like a panic type of state that's what
happens when Consciousness drops into
the body it's disoriented completely it
doesn't and so what it does is start
grabbing you just call it clinging it
starts grabbing to Mommy to crib to
blanky to toy to you're saying that it
just grabs anything that's steady
that'll get it hands on and starts to
build some solidity inside it's not
really solid it's it's just thoughts
it's experiences and but they're firm
they're regular always put the baby in
the same crib don't do the experiment
without having to put a baby in a
different crib every night and a
different mother picks them up because
every psychologist would say that's out
of the question right because your the
self the conscious is going through this
experience of trying to ground of trying
to settle okay I know who I am I am this
person's child I am the owner of this
crib I am the one who has this blankie
okay so you develop a self-concept and
that gives you a sense of stability and
then you keep that throughout your
entire life so the fact that you don't
remember
what your caution was like before you
did all that is completely
understandable great Masters say they do
it's none of my business okay you're
gonna understand it was totally
conscious in the womb and they know
where they were before okay so it's nice
if somebody says that but I don't want
you to say that I I want you to be real
and what real is there was a tumultuous
period until you started to build this
self-concept and all psychology will
tell you that you build a concept of
yourself and then the Consciousness
rested on that
and said at least now I know who I am
a person who lives here on the person
that has this mother daddy this and that
right and you've done that your whole
life on the person that married so and
so I'm the person that got divorced
that's not who you are those are the
experiences you've had not denying the
experiences right but you're collecting
experience you had and then saying
that's who I am no you're the one that
had the experience so that's my level I
don't want to add to the belief
structure that you're supposed to
believe something about what happens
when you die or believe something or
where you were before you were born to
me it's irrelevant it should not be an
important thing in your life what should
be important is finding out who's in
there who's in there and why do they
keep getting pulled down into the
thoughts and down into the emotions and
down into what's the tiniest little
things happen in the world if someone
were to listen to this conversation from
the seat of awareness what what would
that be like how would they do that
that's jumping ahead a whole lot but
let's start there okay
you are aware
people don't pay attention to the fact
that they're aware but obviously they're
aware you see through your eyes you hear
through your ears and you you feel touch
and so on
who does that what does that your eyes
don't see you see through your eyes your
skin passes messages back to you your
ears pick up Sound Vibrations send them
back to you who is that in there and
where in there it's not really
everywhere there's a place inside of
yourself from which you listen that's
why some meditation techniques are very
beautiful they tell you to just listen
listen to quiet listen to whatever
sounds there pay attention listen then
you really realize you're in there
trying to listen
so basically but but you're asking a
deep question the Deep answer is you're
inside and if you meditate and you pay
attention and work with witness
Consciousness you're going to find out
that there is a place in there where you
are and that the sites that are coming
in are outside of you even inside your
thoughts are outside of you you'll feel
that they're at a distance from you
because you're sitting in a center of
Consciousness and then you're projecting
your Consciousness onto objects of
Consciousness why would meditation work
what's meditation got to do with me
who's in here and struggling with myself
meditation is very very simple in the
simplest sense
the simplest meditation nowadays that's
taught is 15 minutes in the morning 15
at night sit down and watch your breath
go in and out well what's so holy about
watching your breath go in and out
what's that got to do with yoga
if you are watching your breath go in
and out you are not watching your mind
complain about what's going on
you're not letting your mind you're not
watching the mind that is participating
in the game of what I want what do I not
want and how do I make it happen you are
instead focusing your awareness on the
breath going in and out believe it or
not that will completely change your
life why
for the very reason that you're not
participating in the Disturbed mind the
mind will always be disturbed if the
foundation of the mind is what do I want
what do I not want and how do I make it
happen
that is very disturbing because you have
pitted yourself against the unfolding of
reality in front of you if you watch
your breath go in and out or any other
technique of meditation you use whatever
is comfortable to you works for you if
you're watching your breath go in and
out you are not watching your mind live
your life decide what should be
happening and getting upset or excited
about it that very Act of not watching
the Disturbed mind permits you you in
there the one that I said are you in
there hi
you're in there but you're watching your
mind all the time and participating in
the mind's attempt to make things be the
way it wants
all you can be responsible for is
yourself your starting position is right
you have to evolve with the different
situations that are presented to you and
my experiences if you do that
the rest will happen the people around
you will be raised naturally understand
that like if you bring anger into a
situation imagine a household or always
fighting if all of a sudden somebody's
not and somebody's bringing
understanding and love that's all they
have to do it will change things
right but you you can't sit there and
say I won't change until everybody else
does
that doesn't work
right so that you're asking you like
there's no surprise you I said big
things all right it's like can it be
better of course it could be better but
it requires that everybody work on
themselves
because while they're not working on
themselves they're working on everybody
else every single moment is an exciting
challenge to do your best to bring your
A game to everything that's going on
right it's like sports I shouldn't talk
about it now but anyways you know
sometimes we win something we lose the
question is did you enjoy the game did
you get better because of it if you
played a competitor that was better than
you that's wonderful you learned you
understand that it's the same thing with
relationships if you're in a
relationship and it didn't work out
that's fine there's nothing wrong with
that did you learn did you grow are you
better now to move on with your life
every single moment of life is a
learning experience to understand that
the point that I see I get across to
people I say to you you are always
better on I'm in trouble and I'll step
back you are always better off having
had an experience than not having had it
you are a holder person because you had
an experience do you understand that if
you didn't ever travel somewheres then
you didn't have an experience if you
didn't ever fall in love you don't know
anything about it you're a novice you're
nothing right you are when you have an
experience when life gives you the gift
of an experience and you experience it
and you learn from it how can you tell
me you're not better off than you were
before you had the experience it can't
make you worse off unless you resist the
experience
and then it can really make you worse
off candidate if you don't like the
experience and you resist it it can ruin
your life but the fact that you got to
have the experience is really special
it's a special thing it's a thank you
this gives you a taste of how a mindful
person lives but you can't just decide
to live like that because then you're
going to suppress the issues you have
inside right you're going to come to me
and say but what if somebody dies but
what do I do if this happens right you
didn't catch on yet right get yourself
together be happy inside be whole Feel
Complete right Feel Love pouring up
inside of you because you don't have
this junk stored inside of you then go
out and bring that into this world with
enthusiasm with passion with love right
and interact with every single thing
that life brings before you with a sense
of honor and respect and gratitude for
the right to be able to do that you have
the right to live like that if you're a
student love going to school don't go to
school saying graduate and then go get a
job nurse what are you crazy school is
one of the need especially College
that's got to be one of the new
experience you'll ever have in your
entire life do you understand that
somebody's paying for you
don't go and listen to smart people tell
you stuff you didn't have to go on the
web and read they sit there and tell you
well what do you do I went to sleep like
come on right you get to the point or
you or you I can't wait to get on and
meet my boyfriend it's always about
something else the reason is because
you're not okay and if you're not okay
you can't enjoy what's happening to you
you have to be looking for the thing
that will be okay that will make you be
okay so we have the groundwork down the
problem here is that you're not okay
inside if you were okay inside your life
would be totally different wouldn't it
you understand that like relationships
you're wrong if you think a relationship
is supposed to make you feel love
is supposed to make you feel needed and
whole and important that's wrong that's
wrong you're supposed to feel love to
start with that's natural love is part
of your being you're supposed to feel
whole and complete within yourself right
tremendous openness and power right now
go out and share it with another person
that's a relationship don't need and
then get upset because they didn't give
it to you never say that there's no way
it's my view I've done it for 45 years
right there's no way that if you can't
fix what's wrong with you inside there's
someone else is going to do it
they don't even know you they get their
own problems you understand that your
mind is a very great thing it is
brilliant it took metals and sand and
taught the sand to think and silicon and
took metals and made a rocket ship got
inside and flew to the moon
oh my God you are brilliant I have a
brilliant mind okay that's not the
problem the problem is what you're doing
with it when you go to that brilliant
mind you say I'm not okay because I
store all this junk inside of me figure
out how everybody else needs to be so I
can be okay
there's a total misuse of mine stop it
that's what you do that's your Technique
stop doing that don't use your mind for
that that's the personal mind don't use
your mind for that use your mind for
great things don't use your mind for
sick things but then what do I do about
the fact that I'm not okay fix it
don't make everybody else be different
so you can be okay don't have all these
rules about how everything needs to be
so you feel better find out why you're
not okay how's that who does they work
at the root that's the root right well
why am I not okay I told you you just
weren't listening you're not okay
because you shoved all this stuff inside
of you of every single experience you
ever had in your life that bothered you
they weren't comfortable with they're
going to be things that are
uncomfortable you see a rattlesnake all
coiled up rattling that's not
comfortable I probably should have seen
them all right that's supposed to scare
you you gotta straight that's why he's
doing it it's not wrong it's not bad it
didn't ruin your life it's a heck of an
experience in fact does that mean I
should go pick it up no you respect the
experience you're having and then you
let it pass you're a greater being
because you had that experience every
experience you have makes you a greater
being because you had the experience I
don't know how to explain that to you
why do you practice tennis why why do
you when you practice tennis you just
have the ball you know ball server that
brought up my server have it come
exactly where your strength is every
single time so you can get better at
where you're strong no you hit it all
over the place why because every single
angle you get better because you use
those muscles and because you came in
tune right or wrong practice makes
perfect well if practice makes perfect
in sports why does practice not be
perfect in life
experience is your best teacher
therefore every single experience you
have you have it and it passes through
you don't hold on to the rattlesnake so
that you miss the next experiences honor
and respect the experiences you had
everyone the divorced at this the
children traumas I don't care I'm
serious stop it you're not a victim
you're somebody who received the gift of
experience how's that the fact that it
wasn't comfortable with the rattlesnake
wasn't comfortable fine that's part of
the experience Let It Go I'm glad I had
that experience now I know better about
rattlesnakes I met one okay I know how
to deal with it well okay fine you've
met divorce your parents got divorced
wonderful you win the person whose
parents didn't get divorced they lost
they didn't get to have that experience
that's how you have to look at it every
single experience you have is this
weight in gold it's a gift from God and
it's your gift because nobody else had
your experience so you process these let
them go that's your spiritual path if
meditation helps meditate Mantra helps
do Mantra but the purpose is not
meditation or Mantra or any other
techniques the purpose is are you
willing to stop storing inside of you
the things that were difficult when you
had the experience because otherwise you
store difficulty inside of you it's
going to be there all the time you
understand that you have a bad smell
don't collect them and take them home so
you put them in a room and remember how
bad it was and how much you didn't like
it just let it pass open the windows or
tone I don't know what to do when I get
a scrum cut I always forget but just let
it go and it'll be over it'll pass don't
never drive down that road again don't
you hear me let your experiences pass
and they will have fed you you'll become
a holder person because you had them you
don't need to hold them in your mind
that is spirituality and now I showed
you why spirituality and life are the
same thing aren't they that's the
highest way to live your life that's the
highest way to become spiritual so find
a way to work with yourself inside
instead of trying to use your mind to
avoid yourself don't let your mind say
how you want things to be or not it's so
foreign to people don't
I want things to be the way they are and
what I want is to be able to honor and
respect the reality of the moment in
front of me that's the last want that
gets left that's your work and you work
on that one it's over isn't it
little by little
work with the things that are unfolding
in front of you don't store them honor
them respect them let them pass and
because you're not putting more stuff
down then the old stuff will come up by
itself I promise you don't worry it will
you'll come complain the old stuff will
start coming up Let It Go
Let It Go you do not want any of it in
you let it go if it needs to come up Let
it welcome it sing hey come on up you're
welcome here kiss it throw a party
really tell you the worst stuff you have
in there welcome it up just relax and
release as it comes up and it'll go
it'll pass not all at once it'll pass
and where do you see I'm telling you
your energy will come free inside you'll
wake up in the morning with ecstasy
pouring with your being not worried
about what happened
and then all through the day I feed you
it rises up inside of you feeding
feeding that's what your life's supposed
to be like the happening place right if
you can't handle it no matter what it is
I don't judge that somebody else
couldn't handle something I can because
if everything is I can't handle they can
all right so it's called compassion
understanding right so I don't judge
that but when it comes in
you say I can't handle it well if you
can't handle it you shouldn't be dealing
with it because you're the worst person
in the world to handle it because you
said you couldn't
right I say I can't pick something up
don't tell me why don't you pick it up
because I said I can't
so instead you sit there and say and
there's an entire path and this works
people run me from all over the world
you know my first book you know the
untethered Soul four million copies
published in 38 countries all right why
I didn't do anything right you're just
talking about what I learned and they
said it works what works it works to say
I'm going to handle this because the
cost of not handling it is it will
bother me for the rest of my life if I
think that bothered me now hear me
somebody yelled at me but then they went
away they don't yell at you every second
right they yelled it to they went away
if I can't handle that they yelled at me
right as bad as it felt that feeling
will stay inside of me my entire life
which is better learn how to say fine
people had a bad day they yelled at me
they took it out on me right and that's
all that really happening right people
people don't yell when they're okay if
somebody's happy and filled with love
their joy and they just their entire
existence is filled with exuberance they
don't yell at people right that's when
you're not okay inside that you see as
an opportunity to let some of this
energy out and you yell at people all
right so at some point you don't take a
personal that's very deep we're talking
very deep you're taking don't take it
personal not yelling at me they're just
yelling I just happen to be standing
there when they're yelling
okay well that happens to kids right you
got a father drinks a father that had
anger problems the kid that fine the kid
didn't need dinner right or didn't do
this a tiny little thing and all of a
sudden this all this anger and
frustration a lifetime worth anger
frustration is coming out on the kid the
kid didn't do anything has nothing to do
with the kid it has to do with the
father and at some point you're mature
enough to realize that they're not
yelling at me they're just yelling and
happen to be standing where they're
yelling I thought I would like them to
be so the problem is that I'm so
uncomfortable inside that my mind can't
be free it's too busy
excuse me puking up all the garbage that
I stored in there it just keeps coming
back up and I can't be okay so the
answer is to be willing to work on
yourself and sit there and say what if I
could handle the day that's happening
now and didn't store more of this
garbage inside okay and
when stuff came up from before you know
to go find it it'll find you when stuff
come up from before I'm committed to
letting it go right and that becomes
that's the spiritual path that's the
entire spiritual path all right is
letting go of what is blocking you
inside and what is blocking you is the
stuff you stored in there you will find
that as you let that go all of a sudden
every day is a little happier all of a
sudden every day's a little lighter if
criticism creates reaction inside which
of course it does like you said in most
people then are you willingness used to
say use it to go to God I always love
that I keep that with me are you willing
to say hey I bothered meditating you
told me all these intense practices you
did is fasting this all you've read all
stuff I used to do right here it is
here's a moment where the very thing
that is keeping you from the ascent has
shown its face to you are you willing to
use that for your spiritual growth and
that has to be deep deep inside and the
answer is yes of course I am okay then
you need to bring these Energies what
happened there when you got hot in the
energy got hot and the breath went
faster the snippy comments is that
basically it hit a blockage it hit a
blockage expanded out and so basically
what your willingness to do is to say I
can stay centered in the midst of that
blockage and I can relax so the key is
relaxing you're right we didn't talk
about that because Letting Go those are
just words the key is can I relax in the
face of the reaction and when people
come to me and say well the anger won't
relax of course not anger doesn't know
how to relax defensiveness doesn't know
how to relax but you who's experiencing
I love you obviously were talking to me
from a place of witness Consciousness
because you described to me what it felt
like to have that reaction that meant
you were in there noticing it you who
notices it wants to do something about
it to make it stop that's why you have
these snippy comments that's why you
attack or whatever run away whatever it
is right fight or flight right no what
you need to do about it is relax if
you're relaxed instead you gave us some
space to release so you're absolutely
right it is not breathe and let go that
doesn't mean anything
those are just words they don't mean a
single thing what it means is catch your
breath for a moment make a commitment I
want to use this to go to God I want to
use this for my spiritual growth I want
to use this to liberate myself from
myself all right there now you have your
intention now I'm asking you to relax
it's not easy you'll see the energy
tries to pull you into it right that's
what you're trying to do right it tries
to pull you in to get you to feed the
reaction instead you relax and just the
very Act of relaxing leave some space
for a little bit of it to pass through
the more you relax the more you lean
away from the energy that's making all
the noise the more space you leave and
that's a very very deep spiritual
practice to relax and release I call it
r r to relax and release everything all
the time first let go that's what I mean
by let go relax and release now deal
with the situation don't deal with your
reactions because you made it this far
in a video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
it's a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome for some amazing jota spends
that motivation check the video right
there next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there when you begin to create from the
field instead of from matter the only
way you can do that is you have to learn
how to take all of your attention off
your body and become a nobody take all
of your attention off all the people in
your life that you give so much of your
attention